Okay, I'm gonna go pee.
Hey guys!
Sorry, we're pivoting a little bit.
We're gonna play a little bit.
I got sucked into an aisle group.
I have my first time playing aisle.
I don't know.
Let me know.
Sounds okay.
I don't know.
Sound guys here.
Yeah, we're waiting for that new guy that we got.
If he's back in time, he's back in time.
You know what I'm saying?
Wait, I'm saying you were gonna leave me, but you weren't
gonna leave the random we randomly picked up?
guys careful yo what up guys i just heard i just trying to
drink a drink to the pond
we're donos we're raptors we're no pack let me know this
sounds good yeah we have a we have a rep all right so
they're sure for we're using mumble for this by the ways you
can't file so they're like just this is apparently it's a
mumble thing so you can't tell voices yeah also i would
highly suggest watching sure force vaude at the beginning
because sure for was churpering me we're the first half of
this so hey that's our friend don't worry we'll pivot we'll
pivot to james bond soon i just got accidentally sucked into
an io group in between streams around that i lose a few
people at least gonna get burnt man they said chase guys i
would highly recommend watching the sure for vod i joined
for the first half because because it was wild i technically
technically i lived the longest out of this pack but the and
sure for died before me by the way guys because he was
trying to it was the leon slash ashley thing where he was
leon and that was ashley and i was like the escort mission
and while he in the middle of escorting a random dino ran in
and killed sure for and it was just me and i was left alone
the random it was like a drive-by he dies on the bridge and
i survived check this and he was like how the did you
survive and then we had to find each other again debbie get
why are we waiting for it i can't you see we're waiting for
Annie.
Oh, I'm back.
I'm back.
No, no, she's bad.
Wait, Ashley, give me like, give me like two minutes.
My dog needs food.
Oh my god, bro.
Why don't you just fucking do that while Annie was gone?
I didn't because that, do not hear him.
He's barking now.
He just started barking.
Guys, I'm so sorry about my dog, man.
Have a good day.
Dog a raptor?
I've never heard of them.
Alright, once Doki is back from their dog, then we can go
bro why these aloes iron us up bro hello i don't know i
thought these aloes were chill now they know i'm married man
oh oh we can actually get in there wait what the what's up
guys i'm I'm going on a reactor now.
What are we doing?
You're too big.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who's this guy?
Is he friends?
The size of these motherfuckers.
I thought allos were like a similar size to us.
Are you prime?
You on prime, bro?
You're big as hell.
That makes sense.
I'm a big chunky boy right now.
How long are you been alive for?
Oh!
Ben!
Oh my god.
Did he...
Was that uncle Ben?
Bro, that's our uncle Ben.
Bro, you killed our uncle Ben.
Wait, where is Surefire?
Where did he go?
Wait, did you kill Surefire?
Did you kill Surefire?
He killed Surefire!
it man wait you gotta be so pissed wait is the afk yeah he
didn't say anything did you kill sure for while afk i think
so they were on top of them right sure for are you alive no
i'm kidding
i said so we're getting revenge yeah we're getting revenge
right now wait wait i'm cool you guys Dude, this is why
being friendly is fucking ass.
Well, we don't deserve to die.
Actually, it's worse that it's first it's on, oh, I have to
go pee.
Oh, I have to go pee.
Oh, I have to go pee more.
Let's do nothing.
And then I was running away and I'm looking back and I see
three people still sitting on the rock.
Are they getting attacked?
Stripping, what do we do?
What do we eat?
We fucking kill, we fucking kill, man.
We gotta kill the black one.
He's the one he killed Shul for.
But like, we were not, we're not gonna be able to kill him.
Yo, I'm cool.
We got, you're cool.
There's six of us, bro.
I'm cool.
you okay i'm gonna be real they're fully grown primes we we
will literally lose 1v6 that's exactly what i'm saying we're
gonna lose we have to just leave okay so what okay so yeah
i'll catch up again don't worry yo we we don't fight that we
just run away yo we're just gonna leave all right that cool
i have a suggestion for this what where are we cordial north
jungle all right
He was like 1v9.
He actually ran the way.
All right.
Let's go back.
So we're just going to leave.
Yeah.
Sayonara, guys.
I got a gig of ping dip on that one.
Just fall.
Hey, we'll catch you LaLeo.
And bye-bye.
Catch you later.
Oh, I don't think he wanted us to live.
Oh my God.
There's a mill over there?
Yeah, right.
We got a bucket.
They're cheating us.
There's a bunch of allosaurus over there.
Oh, good.
Bye.
Hey, apparently we got info.
What's the info?
There's a there's a fully grown dino to like our west.
Are we not going to try and find sure for him, Ben?
Or are you going to meet up with us?
Yeah, they're going to have to meet up with us, dude.
They're babies.
We're like, we're the big, big boys.
They go on the way back.
Yeah, I'm today.
We're just, I actually got sucked into an island game.
Sorry, guys.
But we'll just let me die.
We'll pivot.
wait we'll pivot to james bond the moment the moment we're
done yo if you go i'll fix this real quick but i i can't
stand still if i stand still guys i die i lose the pack yeah
if you go east from here you'll find some water can you not
see what happened sure for him ben they just died
what is it i'm a little dinosaur i mean yeah we can you want
to follow yeah we need more we need patrol shit no are we
done with the he was in the big clearing if you guys know
what the big clearing is he was over there yeah that's
where's bro dude i just have we have a no you didn't look
how big you are we hatched like two days ago
Yeah, look at you.
I know you've been working up, bro
Why are you guys picking up another person when we're size
locked already?
Well, because you're like tiny baby bitch ass has to on his
way back into the pack What do you mean earn my way you guys
are looking sitting on a rock when we're gonna chase by a
dinosaur?
Why would you stay on the rock?
reason i died is because i was going away and i was like are
these guys coming or what we need to we as a group now we
need to acknowledge all right we fight first rp second
because we half us rp'd there the other half got eaten yeah
but the people who but the people didn't rp got eaten all
those one of them was being chill and the other one was just
running around killing yo t-rex t-rex t-rex yeah but he was
chill to me okay they actually let me oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i actually right clicked i'm so sorry
thank you dude don't use right click tearing on our group
apart bro watch out for the t-rex avoid the t-rex we're
gonna go get water and then we'll fight our goal needs to be
the kid we're gonna be a while so i think you should just
work on your patrol zones and stuff Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, we can do that on the way to a place and meet
you.
Like, where are you?
We we are in northern jungle right now.
Just say generally east.
We'll meet you eventually.
All right.
Well, you want to have we'll head southeast and we'll yeah,
we'll head southeast.
You guys know it was so hard to get this game to work.
It took me like 15 to 20 minutes to install everything
because apparently you have to install plugins.
You guys saw mumble and I was like, what the fuck is mumble?
And they're like, you don't know mumble.
I don't fucking know mumble.
and just have all you guys know it's user error it takes
like five minutes it didn't take me that long did it no it
took me a while i got a little confused they can like do it
all wait there's food over here ben
all right here we go no you're good you're good well i see
an enemy i'm trying to catch him it's a headbutter i'm on
him i'm eating him i forgot sure force like not with us
reach out thank you thank you wait i think i can pause now i
can actually set stuff up oh he's dead i'm gonna relax here
and be let accidentally got into a isle into an aisle into
an aisle group what was he gonna say i'm gonna what
everybody's leaving everybody's leaving is he in our diet oh
he is yeah it's up in the tree look wait smell another elf
over here is there another is there someone up there it's a
dead body why is there a dead body up on the tree okay so
there's like these dinosaurs that can climb trees and
they're really scary because they like yeah but if he's dead
then how did he die up there no no he like took food up
there oh that's some good rp like a squirrel That's a good
RP.
Oh, there's food!
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay, let me get some why again.
Nice.
Got my food.
Oh, we have our little pack, guys.
Shrippin's our pack leader, because he has the most
experience.
Alright, now I can finish typing.
Dude, he sounded so happy.
okay
yeah yeah don't you come eat i did i'm full i'm so i'm so
full now yeah i'm gonna eat more actually i'll be extra full
okay because i'm greedy this might be bad this might be if
you overeat your vomit oh okay wait dinosaurs can vomit i
think i saw I was risking myself the biscuit though.
I don't think you have perfect diet yet.
I do.
I got the luck.
Sound yeah.
Is everyone good?
One thing first play is we go northeast to Highland in the
migration zone and the PZs and then go south from there.
Have a gag reference?
Yes sir, pack leader.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're going northeast.
We just follow this path basically.
Sure, four and Ben are close to us.
Oh, hang on.
The others are getting war, I think.
What are they doing over there?
Wait, one guy is so far.
There's two of them over there.
Do you think they're...
Wait, do you think they're reproducing?
Dude.
I don't think they're old enough for them.
Wait.
Maybe they just...
We've met them after, right?
So they're not part of the main group.
Wait, you're right.
Yeah, they could be...
you could be making a family I have like half half sandwich
yeah we don't have to run we can just just chill yeah we can
hurt too you have 16 and then walk there's so many of us
nobody's gonna kill us careful for the dillkey bird you're
more likely to die that is not true that is not true I've
never killed a dino in my life ricks I've never killed a
dino in my life yeah but how many make bleed how many of our
unkind have you made bleed it's an accident some people have
accidents it's okay once twice accident the third time is
when you have to worry you never play rough with anyone
golly do you never do not have friends that's what friends
do i just hatched today today oh i'm not gonna lie i've
loved like some people before yes see you just don't have
friends gully and that's okay we'll be your friend we were
born we were born today man we haven't had a chance did you
guys come from egg no well i mean it doesn't everyone you
know it doesn't everyone god sent me down here yeah that was
a laboratory I was grown in a loud, you know, you heard of
Jurassic Park.
See, Ben, this is why you can't be too friendly.
Because now there's a Jurassic Park.
They keep asking us to join group, but we can't.
I did that accident.
Hold on.
Wait, how far are you guys from us?
I did hear that.
How far are you guys?
We need to stop answering.
We're in North Lake.
We're pretty far.
Oh, you're pretty far.
But you guys made friends, though, at least.
tunnel right so many omniraptors i mean i'm going around the
wrong way i'm trying to get my why maybe we gotta go is that
tunnel i don't think so no it's not no it's just a parking
lot that stops or something i can kill it's just the void
just a glimpse just eclipsed into my freaking dark twisted
mind here's something that's where you were born gully
we're wait where is i'm gonna follow stripping
far why is he like away from the group the main group yeah
this is a james bond game no yeah we're reincarnated to
dynos so what's the plan shipping we got uh if we want alpha
we need to go yes to island but also touch the migration
zone we're trying to uh go back to our old group and then
once we've touched them all we're gonna go south and try and
find our two long-lost can we die of old age in this game
enough people you can just like uh you can't dive but once
you hit fully grown you become an elder and you like lose
some of your stats become older shit and then you can like
prestige your dino and be reborn but you keep all of your
mutations oh so like so like if you're an elder can like the
other dynos can protect you and you can live on a prime
elder you're still stronger than a regular uh adult oh i see
prime that's why we gotta get prime yeah have you guys heard
of amazon prime i've never gotten prime i'm not gonna lie
i've never lived this long oh you just got it nice oh nice i
feel like you've lived another life somewhere else oh is
that catalyzm oh is that catalyzm oh no i didn't i think
it's a dialogue i was pouncing on the dead body wait wait
wait i see someone in the i see someone in the bushes in the
bushes wait wait i think he ate you look west in front of me
person wait i thought this is this not cannibalism is this
not a raptor oh we can eat this okay all right how do you
know uh i don't know i couldn't tell but you don't get sick
oh yeah like you tell me the head see the head's weird ah
it's like a weird head i see i see food is food guys you
just fill up all of your little staffing so you get a pay a
subscription how do i get it oh oh and then after you pick
you have to go to amazon.com and then you can buy amazon
prime you gotta get perfect diet you have to touch two
migration zones and four patrol zones never
dude my diet is right now it's just water and let me see see
guys this is like what if james bond was a dinosaur making
me pick it up and not give me the testing yeah what is he
whoa there's a data in front of us he friendly that's a
sarah that's not that's not one of us i don't think the
shaking is working i don't think i think he i think he ran
when he saw so many of us he got scared does this get me
yeah already full as long as wait sureford made me e-fly me
earlier oh they're not friendly they are not friendly invite
them bro wait i'm bleeding i'm not inviting bro i'm telling
i'm not trying to overgroup man i need a heal i'm bleeding
they already have someone that they invited i got ambushed i
can't tell if that's a rapture wait are you okay no no i'm
healing i'm healing i'm bleeding a hera dropped on you can't
help you hey there little guy he's calling me a piece of
poop are you guys friendly i think this is a baby
gotta read them oh we just met we just found each other on
in the aisle yeah i don't get any nutrition the name drops
can we join you guys oh you guys are full uh i think we're
we're looking for two little friends all right i thought he
was another raptor at first yeah there's a big guy stalking
us to the east oh my god i can i can get intestines yo doc
as soon as yours bleeds it has a white plus on it we have to
move yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm almost down I'm almost good I
think I actually think that stegos friendly well he has to
be friendly he's an herbivore no don't say that stegos can
be rude why are they rude why is it doing this I was just I
got
guys i'm going to strip in no there he is there he is am i
too small oh my god they're fighting fucking rex going one
of the allies bro yo have the rest of the beast why not it's
just me in the green base oh yeah you're not yeah it's third
party fight fight fight yeah you got him you got him He
says, yeah, I'm good.
Yeah, fuck that guy.
My plate is at 0%.
I'm gonna die.
Wait, who's that?
Who's dying?
Is it one of us?
I think we're cool.
We're good.
We're chill.
Wait, there's a kid.
They have...
Oh my god, food!
Oh, you did?
Yeah, it's dead.
What in the fuck did you kill a hair?
What a little guy.
Yeah, let me get some wine.
Look at this bitch, gully.
Trust the fuck.
Wait, that's the guy that prompts me!
Fuck that guy!
Yeah, fuck him!
Eat him!
That's the guy that drop kicked me!
You're not so tough now.
Dude, what a fucking shadow.
Wait, who's this little guy next to us?
He was on a little branch, so I jumped and pounced and
grabbed him.
I just...
He's a tiny little baby, Miss Grace.
Hey, little cat.
I just lost him, Miss.
I actually lost three war from that Rex, to be honest.
Oh, you lost your family?
Yeah, I lost three.
Oh!
Hey, were those your parents that just got killed?
Huh?
That T-Rex didn't.
Oh, his T-Rex didn't.
Your parents, dude?
You cool?
Yeah, yeah, man.
Hey, you're like, uh, you're like Batman now.
It's like you're like, to kill you right right right good
luck man possibly i did i was here earlier and then i uh i
wasn't you are i recognize your voice pulling out organ i
ended up storing and i grabbed something oh yeah yeah let me
grab let me pull some out for you i got my revenge what do
we do about this guy now that's following in us in our group
it's fine we just take him and then he'll group with the
people that are in there That's fine.
We need more.
I'm yam-yam.
Should we move on?
I think we're starting this game.
Probably.
Yeah, we all just happened to meet up today.
Yeah, don't mess with us.
We're big.
Wait, are you trying to reset your spawn?
They don't speak for us.
Don't disrespect the big guy.
I'll just one show you.
Whoa.
That's how we cool.
I got a washer.
Whoa.
Jeez.
Yeah, bro.
Look both ways before you swing that tail, bro.
Rex gets Rex, Rex, Rex.
Oh, shit.
T-Rex, T-Rex, T-Rex.
I'm chill, man.
You chill?
It's run from the T-Rex.
Everybody run.
Are you cool?
I didn't say that, but what do you think?
Yeah, okay, but we, but you're a T-Rex.
Why are you a T-Rex then?
Oh, there's another T-Rex down there.
Yeah, there's another Rex straight that way.
He came through here like a wall.
He came out of the fog.
Yeah, that's why we're scared.
It's trauma.
Whoa, what if you fight that T-Rex, bro?
I bet you're stronger than him.
Yeah, I bet you're so much stronger than that other T-Rex,
bro.
Are you having muscle spasms, Mr. Rex?
No, I think it's way worse to have someone in your mouth and
then kick them later.
We're not kicking them.
We're putting him to the other...
Yes, sir!
Bro said we're not kicking him.
We're putting him in a different group.
I need it.
We're kicking him.
I'm gonna go back to them.
What do you mean we're not kicking?
We're in the hunt.
Who's that to our, uh...
There's one of us.
There's someone in front of us?
There is someone in front of us.
There's a couple in front of us.
Yeah.
Let's go somewhere safe.
I don't feel very safe.
We are safe.
There's a...
Are you friendly?
What are we even looking at?
Sky boys, let's go.
They don't look friendly.
Yeah, they are not probably.
Oh, they do not look friendly.
Why you got food stuck in your mouth?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
These are not my crew.
All I'm saying is, Ben, is you're gonna have to break the
news of the guy that...
Sorry, we gotta kick you out of the group.
It's not okay.
We're still trying to find her.
Streets are saying you gotta get pounced on.
Oh, there's a lot of downers here.
Yes, by your rector.
Just do it quick, Dahlia, right?
Do what, Claire?
I just brought a sword.
Just a quick bounce and then space board to get it.
Yeah, just pounce and jump.
Do you want me to do it?
I don't wanna be there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you don't fall off.
I got it.
Wait, what are you guys doing?
Whoa, why are we killing him?
Yeah, perfect, perfect.
You saved my life.
I guess now I need to heal that bleed though.
Wait, why did we do that?
Sorry.
I was, I was, I had food stuck in my mouth.
Hey, can we find some water?
Oh yeah, I might need water soon.
Yeah.
I have to wait for my plus to come out of my bleed.
Yes, I can move.
Okay.
I'm gonna go chill then.
I'm chilling here too.
There's actually a lake straight east of us once everyone's
ready.
I'll bring up overall, including the voice.
Okay.
bring up bring up overall the voice chat is in game yeah i'm
gonna be going out for yo s4 where you at big g all right
brought up a little right now we're currently at the uh damn
lake okay we're at highland all right we're gonna be there
soon all right you want to stay in highland yeah you guys i
mean we should just keep heading to you and hitting pz's
with it don't worry guys james bond soon i'm just stuck in
an aisle group right now i'm stuck in a squad if the ass
people squad up a little bit in aisle and i didn't think we
would play that long so many of us can be in a group and i
don't die as often we got the squad up this is your first
time i got kidnapping all right listen up we've only got
five percent left until we get prime trigger we have to hit
a couple more pz's all right we do that in five percent yeah
yeah yeah there's one right south of us and then there's one
north of the other side of the lake so we're gonna hit it
right yeah we're gonna all right let's go so first one is
this way
all right here we go guys i can fortunately i won't be
joining him in the prime journey i'll be the not because i
actually became a cannibal
what do we do when we're here we just chill man all we have
to do is touch it oh we just touch Someone's running for us
right now.
Hello, grass.
It's one of us, I think.
No, I think it's just Sarah.
Yeah, yeah.
And then, now, we're gonna go northeast to the lake, and
we're gonna drink.
Okay.
How many hours you have on this game's tripping?
You know so much about it.
And then I have to go backwards where you guys just came to
get my PZs.
I don't have perfect diet, so I'm just kind of here for the
ride.
That's cool.
It's okay.
It's okay, same here.
It's all right, we're just chilling.
As long as we roll into here.
We can be, they'll protect us because they're prime.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, dude, the second we see you, we'll just
escort you down to your PZs and shit.
We'll just make sure you get rid of them.
I mean, I'll probably die again somehow, but.
No, no, no, no.
Lesson learned, man, I'm not, I literally, if someone comes
towards us or friendly and shit, I'm just pouncing.
Yeah, we can pretend to be friendly, and then we pounce
them.
Sure, four has died the most, guys, out of all of us.
We had a lot of rapture mounts to him.
I'm not sure if we're has died more than all of us.
But to be fair, I cost 50% of those deaths.
Finding random people and inviting them to a group.
We're going to drink here.
I'm going around the mountain, man.
I'm drinking.
Yeah, but watch out for the Rexes behind us is the only
thing.
Let's go to the other side.
Yeah, let's go around.
Let's go around.
Come on.
Where's the Rexes?
We need to kill a Rex.
Behind us.
Dude, there's a Rex with like a teenager Rex, a school in
him.
we killed the teenager rex oh by the way you'll be pleased
to know you know that the one that kills you sure for yeah
did you guys fuck him up he he followed us to highland and
he was like striding around trying to scare us and a rex
that was hiding in a bush just instantly pinned him and
killed him dude that's good it was unbelievable is it is it
better the discord audio sound yeah and then he was like no
please no you poop eater yeah because he was probably six
Wait, what T-Rex take that long to level up?
T-Rex take like 15 hours to grow.
Yeah, it's a full size.
Like, is it just 15 hours one session or you can continue,
like a continue?
I mean, you can log out and like, you can log out and keep
going.
But if you want to be a prime T-Rex, the T-Rex is just
slowly swimming over.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't.
I mean, you should never be caught by a T-Rex's raptor
unless he ambushes it.
is we we could go for the little one right now wait there's
there's more of us than them and then we'll ruin his build
he kills us in one bite though okay oh wait there's another
t-rex over there that's why you gotta be quick pristine our
our our powers are speed just keep running away from that
slow ass yeah he's he's looking for us right now all right
let's go to a pz come on we time it's a good thing is brains
the size of a walnut yeah i think our brains are smaller
isn't it i might be like a pea though hey i'm a philosopher
i'm a philosopher after my brain's the size of what even
bother all my stamina is low now guys i can't keep running
anymore
Wait, I think I heard Doki.
Hello?
Wait.
Sure for?
Head his way.
Hello?
Can you give me a...
Stamp in, Doki.
Yo, Doki's standing up as well.
Yo!
Yo, get me in.
Get me in.
Yo!
Alright.
Come on, send an invite.
And the group is full, boys.
No, no.
Can you guys invite us to your...
so we can just like jump ship yeah let's invite us oh you're
so small you guys are little babies look at you guys look at
this tiny little babies wait wait wait we got company ice
king ice king what's up i'm back he's back okay but we gotta
be like stripping stripping was going north are you guys all
the same group
the group wait who's this that's sick man i was just hitting
this pz i only got three percent to prime make sure i happen
is it is this useful no this is not it i'm the one with the
battle skies because you know i've i've seen you take me to
where stripping is because i i want to get prime soon wait
where is stripping why do you guys leave then it's this way
why why do you need in order to get prime i'm using this
game you need uh migration zones patrol zones sanctuary i
can't run anymore I don't know why and I already got the I
got the sanctuary too wait how the fuck did I get wounded
wait guys I need to heal up I'm wounded we just use an
online map you can just run right here all right there's a
PZ right here over here in this bush okay we have we have a
bunch of random people in this group now so like okay we
just gotta coordinate leave group sprint a certain direction
and reform without oh wow ben was like oh yeah it's not a
problem we don't have to like make these guys quit the group
they can join the group together his solution yeah we all
just need to coordinate leave and run in a direction like
what the man why are you saying that like that's an
impossible feat it's like it's literally not about it being
an impossible it's the fact that there's a to the west of us
which i need to hit so maybe we could run over to that one
and just reform wait i'm a little injured so i need to heal
a little bit i don't know how i got injured i'm a 67 i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go to that other one and chill i'm coming
over i just can't run because i don't know how i got injured
i'm coming over just hobbling over just hobble hobble let's
just all leave group and run in a direction together hobble
hobble
i'm the idiot yes this whole problem wouldn't be a problem
if we were literally just went sorry guys our group is full
we're gonna have to go where did everybody go I'm just
hobbling.
This is not my group.
I hope this is...
The only person we're missing in our group is Strip and we
have everybody else.
I hope that's my group.
I'm at the thing at the west.
Yeah, Strip and just come west whenever you're done.
I'm at the PZ West.
Are you... I'm here right now.
Yeah, Rive and E Thailand Bridge.
The Red Circle.
wait underneath the bridge you're a highland lake right wait
is that you stripping next to me yeah yeah oh the west one
i'm at the east one you said west like three times yeah i
just wanted to touch the wait strip is that you in front of
me yeah yeah so come to the west one all right we're waiting
here because we we i'm gonna leave this group and i'm just
gonna have okay Wait, I might be lost right now.
I don't know what happened to everybody.
Hey, what's going on, man?
I'm wounded, so I've been hobbling.
I might need someone to pick me up, lady.
Bro.
Why are you so upset?
It's literally working just fine.
It's just not a big deal.
There's no way you can't see the problem that has been
created.
I see the randoms.
I see them, but I don't see you guys.
I see them.
I'm just...
Someone pick me up.
I'm alone.
That's how it's tasty.
Lots.
Wait, who's that?
Who's that that ran past me?
Let's still get them.
Wait, I'm in the same group as Annie.
I'm with the Cherfoy group, but it's the three people he
randomly picked up.
I think they're heading back to you guys.
I'm just, unfortunately, I cannot run right now.
We're chilling at the West PZ right now.
Where's that?
What do you mean?
Where's West?
Doki, just stay with me.
Just stay with me.
You have a map, Doki.
Oh, okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, let's just heal in the bush.
Come on.
Right here.
Oh, my God.
Where did you come from, Stripman?
I didn't even see you.
It's okay.
I have my designated babysitter, guys.
My designated babysitter is here.
Who's gonna be anyway?
No, I lost.
I got Docky with me, but she's too hard to run.
So I'm going to heal her up and then come to you guys.
I'm like, I'm wounded right now.
For us.
Oh.
Just a little baby, guys.
Just a little baby.
Don't worry.
Congenital hypogazia.
We're going to swap soon, guys.
a little bit more that means you won't die as much dude
imagine they just fucking tail swiped us there i've never
gotten this big before that's 75 i'm usually all right once
dokey's healed up just meet us at the actual lake i guess
how long does how long does he'll take depends it feels
faster than what is it you're not like your leg's not
injured or anything right no it's just his wounded oh you're
okay that just means you're on low health we could we can
move like that okay i just can't run though i can't run wait
is your stamina gone yeah my stamina's gone oh all right
tell me when your stamina's food up spamming jump it's the
lead i have one mutation
wait how did i become the group leader you guys all leave
the group did you guys all leave the group did you yeah we
did wait try to kick this i left it's just you're over
inviting oh nine people group right now no just leave once
you're close to us okay okay but they're gonna follow me
yeah that's the problem we've created unfortunately because
you just leave the group and then run away it's fine i'll
just hang on okay there's no way ben is like dude it's fine
just leave the group and we're alone now like this is you're
unethical man how am i unethical you are alone see the
problem with what you're gonna leave and reform but you guys
will stay together right oh okay oh they're so sad look what
you did ben yo jokey yeah leave group and come leave group
and come in yeah i'm here i'm here where are you i'm this
one wait which is this one i'm jumping oh i'm here i'm here
Ben, you made them sound so sad and I have to live with
this!
Wait, what did Doki say?
Ben made them sound so sad that he baited the fuck out of
them, thinking they were going to be in a group and now
we're just abandoning them?
Who would have thought?
Who would have said?
I have to live with that!
You're a mistake!
Thanks!
Alright, we're coming over.
I don't know how I got so fucked up.
When we're bigger, Doki, we want to try and only sprint when
we need to.
Because it takes too much stamina.
Okay.
So we can be chilling like this.
Alright.
And then if something comes ours, we fucking run.
Okay.
Do we, do I get regen while I'm just walking?
Or like, not regen stat?
Yeah, yeah.
You heal, you heal a little bit faster when you're sitting,
but you heal over time.
As long as you got good full belly and full water.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, cool.
All right, so show four at the lake.
We're at the lake.
Sure, four.
Oh, Ben's dead.
All right.
I did Ben die.
All right, this guy just kill himself to kill me.
Well, he's not dead.
And he's 1v3ing us at the run because he's playing on water.
Yeah.
Why do I, why do I hear people try to kill?
I'm scared.
Yo, Chufa, do you need help?
We're at the lake, right?
Yeah, there's someone killed Ben.
We're at like the north side of the lake.
I don't know what dinosaur this is.
Where are you going?
Oh, it's someone that makes me hallucinate.
We're trying to find our friends.
Oh, this way, Doki, come on.
Oh, okay.
Careful at the lake.
We, we got, we got killed at the lake.
Or I did.
Two people, Dad.
Wait, I don't have stamina.
We're at the South Lake Shuffle.
We're running over.
We're tripping.
No more inviting people when we're full.
So we don't have to do this shit, man.
You're old to do with anything.
Yeah, I don't know what that has to do with Dialo's getting
you, but.
Are you all dead?
I'm dead.
I have to restart.
I think they're all dead.
Who are you?
Yeah, that's a question.
Wait, they're all dead.
It's just...
I don't know how you keep surviving, Ducky, despite
everything, but it's just...
It's just you and me now, Ducky.
I need to reach out.
Let me reach out.
All right.
Basically...
I just pushed.
This guy came up, fucking killed the Benford, and just kept
on dipping in the pond.
Hey, look, I'm the last one standing.
I mean, it's true.
Dude, you must be fully grown now, Ducky.
I think I am.
How the fuck, dude?
i don't know i keep surviving i feel like i don't know
what's going on okay uh spawning in my game crashed uh guys
i don't know how i i'm always the last one alive somehow i'm
a survivor i'm a survivor can you stop we walked away from
them for can you stop like a minute and we're gone like what
is your issue
i mean there's a new playing dinosaur that was a bad idea
you guys can like invite each other now and get together
right off the bat i have a little clamber in the top left
doki you should kill yourself you go to the no reporters
guys yeah you can like record the game and then like look at
everything in third person like free cam the recording i
don't even see a button to record in the control he means in
game guys i think surely right yeah i mean i think you're
right but he means he means in game guys
you might need to i had to reboot my game but was it doing
like crashed yeah when you connect though does it like
connect then just cancel someone said f2 is record maybe you
accidentally press f2 Oh yeah, that's true.
That is what happened.
Nice.
Wait, are we going to...
Are we trying to find Cherfor's group or are they coming to
us?
We're going to try and find them?
Babies.
Yeah, we're going to have to find them because they're
babies.
But also, you and me need to somehow get out of here without
being killed by everything that killed them.
Who's TPing me?
Maybe they'll be friendly.
Whoever has the closest spawn to them, find out.
And then spawn on that person.
five three eight oh three where did everyone spawn i'm just
chilling in here with stripping west pond like where we were
before oh okay that's yeah that's a good one all right who
is in currently i am everyone everyone go to west pond then
and we'll run over all right did i disconnect with the
plants i'm still I'm wounded.
I don't know how I'm still wounded.
Do you have, like, red around the edge of your screen?
Yeah.
Yeah, that means that you were, like, the more red your
screen is, the closer you were to dying.
You must have been so close to dead.
Oh, my God.
I survived.
Somehow.
What happened?
Did you get bit by something?
I don't know.
I think it was when I don't know.
I honestly don't know what the fuck happened to me.
But I lived.
All right.
Just invite gold, I think.
I'm 37196.
How do I know, like, what my HP is?
um you should have like you press tab you have like the red
around your screen you can't really see your health in this
game it's just like your pulse your pulse on the tab screen
plus how much red is on your screen there's a lot of red
there's a there's a lot we have to get moving though dokey
so let's go all right four nine eight one seven did you get
that it's invite id we walk yeah if we see anything i didn't
get a sprint okay we don't find nothing okay it's an invite
id can i say hi to them all right she wrapped it two raptors
like us two little guys we can't do a lot we can run no we
can run we can run quick nice skilling me in yeah i'm
accepting yeah what's up everyone red is like the hide and
bushes so just keep your keep your eyes peeled okay all
right guys let's get some food where's the nearest uh yeah
okay the near it this this sanctuary is a hot zone so be
careful oh oh you want me to help i can't believe we're
almost back together all of us What's up?
What the fuck is your fight?
Just run.
Why are you going?
Why are you just going to jump by the three dylos that
killed you?
It was just one dylos.
It was one.
Oh, that's three now.
Oh.
tripping balls no that was one guy no it was one guy it was
one guy once you start hallucinating and they send like
clones of shit get away yeah he's god i was like are you
kidding i was like why are you starting to fight with that
guy dude i'm tripping fucking balls right now because that's
the guy that killed show for oh i think i think i got killed
by one of the whole groups you got one guy i know that man
he his like regular bite was canceling my pound He, what he
was doing is when we would pounce him, he would run into the
water to force his belly bounce.
Oh, that's smart.
That is smart.
No, I can't tell what direction we're going in, though,
because I'm hallucinating.
Um, we're going north right now.
All right, guys, be careful.
That's really bad.
We don't want to be going north, but I do need to stop this
bleed, so I'm going to sit in this bush.
All right.
I'll sit in the bush.
Is there really no mine in here?
Oh, there is something.
Yeah.
Push dive.
I like how the guy went after stripping instead of me.
Am I fucking loser?
Noob?
Yeah.
You might be the worst player in the group.
You have two, wait, three deaths?
Yeah, three deaths.
All right, death count.
Who has more than three deaths?
Oh my god.
I think I also have three.
So you're just as good as Ben.
Yeah Oh, I see a little bit.
Ow.
No, you wrap up there.
Oh, no pain.
Ow.
I still fucked up.
Oh, I'm not wounded now.
I'm okay.
It's a little guy.
Okay.
Now I am wounded.
We swapped.
I'm gonna take I'm gonna take a sip of water.
Oh my god.
It's two T-Rex.
It's only five.
Oh my.
T-Rex is careful.
Whoops.
Um, um, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Wait, something headbutted me and ran away.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum.
Surely no one's gonna kill me.
Perfect, uh.
I'm just a little Donald drinking some water.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum.
See, look at that.
Wait, it's the Croven guy.
No, he's inviting us to the crib.
I'm not doing this again.
I'm not doing this.
I'm not doing it.
I'm sorry.
Are you guys inviting more people into the group again?
No, no.
Yeah, sure for inviting people again.
I thought you guys said we have to stop that.
We're not inviting the door.
Okay, thank God I'm perfect diet.
That T-Rex is scary.
Dude, I'm still hallucinating.
How long did this shit lost?
Ow, Akarna was headbutting me.
Maybe you should Google.
The other guys that got hallucination died.
You want to jump me, bitch?
We're just chilling.
Why aren't you guys helping me jump this guy?
I'm bleeding.
Yeah.
Don't worry, I got him.
Good job.
Kill this guy.
Check him out.
Yeah.
See?
Guys, I'm the one that survived the longest.
Good job.
All right.
I got to rest up.
I'm fucked up.
Okay, as soon as I'm not tripping balls, we'll go.
If you spam E on that guy and rip out his organs, you get
the Y.
How long does it take for you to stop tripping balls?
I don't know, man.
I hear, like, whistles and mist and shit.
I don't even know where I am.
I'm stripping as high as fuck.
Bro, you're fucking high as hell, bro.
Do you got to stop with those frogs?
So, Gully and Annie, what you want to do is try and rip out
the organs, which is the Y, and then you get, like, the
heart and stuff, which is a B.
And you just need 1% of Y and B.
and you'll get perfect die so you can get i'll be licking
tones i got the heart i put it on the floor yeah and make
sure you guys share the organ or how do you guys keep the
organs all i've been doing is holding e yeah you press g
once you tear the body open oh you double tap e to rip the
body open as a wrap and then you press g to pull out the
organs all right you guys have to share that why together we
can't share that's one bite no it's not one bite it's like
two bites there's someone coming oh that's another raptor
that's the kind of complicated i've just been walking around
i've been like a little i've been ashley over here all right
he got abandoned and then he just went to the yeah i still
can't smell okay
i have perfect diet too we have to get down to the the boys
we're at the we're at the highlands sanctuary right now can
we get there we were in the highlands before hold up oh i
know exactly what wait that's close yeah that's close
because we were in the highlands yeah this way dokey i'm
heading over abandoning him and showing up as a baby again
is funny no right
like i'm getting punished by god for my decision see if you
sure put me things won't go this way i tried and then you
couldn't even follow me and i got killed by a bridge camping
hara if you sure put me like properly oh my god you're so
big and cool how far are we stripping someone's fucking
dying we're close nice remember where like that big rex
killed all the all the allies and stuff yeah yeah that's
where they are right there i'm gonna get a coke real quick
while i'm freaking rejuvenating boy did you die again i'm
just gonna stay here until stripping gets here what if he
dies while afk look how fucking wounded we are dude look at
you we got all these scars on us yeah we've been surviving
yeah exactly we go find now we have to play parents we're
gonna find our kids oh can i have bad oh wait there's a
deradacta can he kill us a deradacta i mean he can't kill us
hey you friendly up there you enjoying that sky bro how's
how's the sky tonight did you guys log in after the storm
because that sucked whoa whoa whoa oh no oh i'm tripping
balls now i'm tripping balls stripping now wait is stripping
dead oh boy just gonna leave his girl to die no i'm coming
over don't go i got him i got him
oh no i see the clones i don't know which one's the right
one stripping i'm dead run run run just run tripping die oh
god i don't understand how one dialer does that much damage
to it like two fucking sub adult raptors dude look sniff
sniff look at north i'm tripping i'm tripping boss oh shit
just run i'm tripping boss and they're following me wait we
can we can actually exclamation point slain just reset one
more time guys because serena and you're actually here so
when they get here we can do that drowning wait i might be
drowning i guess i guess they fixed the dilo clones yeah
because apparently they were broken before i'm not drowning
i'm okay
the there he's camping me by the way he really really wants
to kill me he's really hot if you got pounce on him i think
you probably would what if he heals up He can't.
He's bleeding.
I bled the shit out of him.
He'd have to, like, stand still and sit down.
Wait.
Dullable's Annie?
Did both of you get Y?
Why is this that?
What is his life?
He's just out there fucking pouncing on people.
How do you...
How do you enjoy this?
I don't know if that's the clone or if I'm tripping walls.
The hallucination, you'll, like, see other... You'll just
see clones of him even if he's not there oh okay i think
that he might not be hunting you you might be looking at
clones i think that's what i'm looking at right now no he's
not he died well you can respond with stripping now oh my
god you said that i was just like i don't know clone and
then he fucking ran over and bit me no the clones the clones
run at you and bite you oh the clones do bit oh my god are
you fucking oh my i just stayed in the water you got killed
by a clone i just stayed in the water i'm now i thought if
they fix the clones that sounds like the dinosaur i need to
play now if i have your solo that sounds that should sound
weird i'd be fine if there was a fucking rock we could be on
dude but yeah no rocks in the whole highland all right
somebody invite me um i think we want to we want to slash
slay and just get everyone together see where you guys spawn
yeah see where you spawn we have perfect dive already and if
you close it i don't know where i am i can just run to you
i'm at check i thought i thought i would live
i'm at rock pond i'm at delta delta's not too far away delta
yeah that was not the worst you want to come to me then
that's an easy run yeah can you add me and then What's your
ID?
Wait, no, first we're to Doki spawn because she might have
spawned closer.
I got to Rockpond, wasn't it?
Let me try, try and just, Doki just put it in the website.
I don't think Doki's gonna know.
I did.
Okay, if you put it in the website, where does it say you
are?
Wait, am I a dam?
Is that?
No.
If you're in a dam, then that's too far away.
Yeah, my thing disappeared.
Okay, well, I'm refreshing this.
what the fuck i'll just i'll just grab you dokey yeah just
grab me dokey just grab the cords and put it in the website
and then say where you spawn or if you don't know take a
screenshot and put it in the discord wait dokey stand still
i can't invite you because you have full you don't have full
stamina wait oh i'm standing i'm lying down oh my god the
t-rex is moving
donkey what are your i put the i put it down i put it down
why don't you just put it you've done it before oh she's
she's in the pit down south that's cooked that's not cooked
that's literally straight south of us and we could just run
towards you that's true isn't that further than delta yeah
way it's way further but there's way more pz's yeah the good
part about the pit is they can go north through the pz's and
we could go through sell through yo all right yeah don't
invite me i invite you okay i need to grab the exclamation
point invite id five three eight three six all right invite
id towards them i guess yeah by id one word space all right
hey yo yay all right i can learn you did it I did it.
That's so freaking epic.
Let's go.
Tripwire doesn't believe in me.
Look how small we are now, dude.
No, I believe in you.
I'm just asking you to put in the cords and I've seen you do
it before.
You didn't.
You put the...
You said put it.
Yeah, the specific.
Yeah, the specific tripwire.
I'm scared this T-Rex is going to fucking charge me.
Get your Fanny.
Oh my god.
There's something...
All right, let's go stealth boys.
Let's get out of here.
We're going to touch all these PZs.
okay then we're gonna go to the crash all right there's
people everywhere good thing it's gonna be so cool i need to
get away from that tutorial voice in my head that was just
talking oh what was what the words was saying what it was
saying it was one of the guys we invited to the group and
then abandoned later what were they just like disappointed
in you or what probably i don't think i'm saying anything
though no he did ask to get invited to the group again yeah
and then i said then we can't and then he left thank god
yeah now we actually have listen all right yeah relax man
look this is this is a star of a beautiful family dude yeah
yeah this is new life new life wait look there's this is
this is actually the first time i'm logging in look at them
are you guys friendly why is he running us like the yes cool
uh i know a lot of people on the server hate raptors oh wait
why do they hate us because we're because they ain't us
because they ain't us we're so cool we're on jurassic park
next pz next pz this way yeah i'm getting i guess it's like
a gated community they're gatekeeping us stand around
they're gatekeeping us dude these freaking herbivores man i
know why can't we coexist think they're so fucking cool
because they eat salad only salad hello yeah they think
they're so cool because they're so big and strong huh you're
so big and strong why are you why are you guys the prey to
the carnivores well if you're a full-grown stego you're
definitely not a prey that's no what about the t-rex your
t-rex is prey yeah t-rex can get you yeah well depends yeah
you think of a vegetarian if the stego gets you with a good
hit in the face it's over dude but but what if it's if you
catch him with like from the side easy win gg easy gg easy
i'm getting us the west rail stuff real quick i feel like
when you're a baby your stamina goes hard yeah because right
legs they don't move as much yeah i feel like my stamina can
go forever now we can start heading straight south where are
we going we're going this way all right
i miss our pack i feel like we've like we need to go to that
crash that you can see over there oh oh yeah i see it Wait,
Annie, Ben, Gully, did I lose you?
There's food that you ran over.
There's food?
Yes.
I feel like we've only been together for like 20 minutes of
the last three hours.
It literally ranged directly over.
You and Shuffle?
Like as a pack of all of us together.
Yeah, yeah, it's true.
Where I did what now?
Whoa.
Just Doki wishing that we were a family again.
i wish we were a fat i miss i miss when all of us were
together well don't worry we're all about to be starting
right next to each other as babies wait what do you mean
because we're all fucking dead what how did you guys die no
i probably still have time to invite you guys if you're dead
no no we didn't die again i'm just saying we died earlier
yeah all right time to wait for ben yeah my yeah my game
crashed too all right time to wait for gully It's not my
fault dude.
It's just it's my first day as a dino Dude, this is their
time.
Yeah, you're gonna say it's the first day At least this time
you're not infertile Dude, wait, I think I'll be late Your
life rule doesn't mean you have to forget being born dude
over and over and over again Born again Nah, I like I like
the RP bro.
Unfortunately my trauma is so strong it goes to my other
lives as well Wait, that's oh yeah yeah it's in his genes
it's coded in his genetics you know how like crows can like
pass on knowledge together it's like that yeah i don't know
that because i'm a newborn raptor what would i know though
like how sure for i just playing this instead of rivals we
don't need to practice bro the game's the same as always
they pull up they pull up fam the oldest oldest you can see
is ours oh well these little trees we're in charge right now
there's no one else here and the second someone else gets
here we're not in charge anymore you understand yeah yeah so
everything the light touches is ours yeah until something
bigger comes along and then oh and then we just gotta kill
it we just have to not get killed by one alloy yo i will say
though loki doki there's a ton of food over here oh hello oh
if you can get b and y get that perfect diet
wait so if i if i inherited trauma can i like inherit like
my crush for that stegosaurus whoa on the stegosaurus she
gave us flowers am i not to eat this tripping or invite me i
think so right next to you it's like a hero i'm where should
i eat it or should i eat it right next to someone where you
all screen i'm next um do you hear that i think that's why
there were dead bodies everywhere stripping did you get
elbow dropped i think i think that's oh my god dude you got
herod yeah she got herod i think that's he actually from the
top rope too i got one shot i can love hera where am i
that's ben dc's body annie we have to wait maybe harris are
calling maybe we should why are we up on fucking raptors why
are we raptors i really i really want to grow as a raptor
and just kill a t-rex like we just gotta get there okay
where's gully hey i'm dead join up i'm waiting for ben ours
to join up where am i now why why are you enjoying
my just my cords i'm gonna freak out i'm gonna freak out
wait we gotta pick up doki because she died she's gotta find
us are you are you back in i'm at the bulk of where am i yo
can we like all slash like exclamation point slay and just
start over no what's great in me
strip are you alive of course i'm alive no i said strip it
did he live i don't know if he lived dude you made him
freaking mute he's like oh dude he died wait wait i live do
you want me to kill myself i'm here how far am i to
everybody bro i just looked you're in the northern jungle
man you're like so far away what the What you decide to do
is deciding my pathing.
So if you're going under here, then...
All right, hi, hi.
Are you guys in Thailand?
We're still in West Rail.
Like the bottom of West Rail?
We're at the bottom of West Rail.
Oh, okay.
You'll need me.
Yeah, Doki, you...
I mean, Operation Survive, I guess, for 10 minutes, and
we'll try and get to you.
I'm like, meeting up with...
I believe.
You know the drill by now, right?
You know what to do, so...
I don't know how to...
She doesn't even know how to use the map.
She's still putting her course in Discord.
Even though I taught her...
to use the map i know how to use the map i know i'm at the
northern jungle okay now use that map to get to highlands
highlands so far no it's not it's really not from where you
are you just have to go southwest i believe in you dude we
were in the highlands anyway remember your past life
southwest.
So, remember the arrow pointing up is north the arrow
pointing down south.
So look at the arrow pointing down and then a little bit to
your right and then to my right.
We saw it left but southwest.
Yep.
But if you're looking at the south, you turn a little bit to
the right and then you're going to southwest.
Okay.
It's just losing his fucking mind, dude.
Isn't this awesome?
I have a great chance.
it's also losing my mind dude we're playing dynos together
yeah i'm a velociraptor roar we're meeting up with stripping
and then we're going to highlands slash northern jungle to
find toky and hopefully she's getting closer to us instead
of farther all right so where are you stripping but i need
to see if i'm going the right way wait are you you're muted
are you new rock pond you're going the right way no i know
i'm going the right way am i going the right way yes yes you
are going oh yeah he's stream sniping you wait what's up og
where are you at right now i'm don't worry about me man i'm
already i'm i'm in south plains right now okay are you on
the left side of george river the right side of george river
because we're on the left side of george river i was just at
the right side but i might loop around left side go through
okay okay do you see that you see that pz that big circle pz
to the left of george river we're there yeah so we can just
wait here you know how about we just i'll set up a discord
overlay i think we need a discord overlay now yeah you gotta
pay i paid with my friend's life man you gotta pay if you
want to slay and then traverse a dokey be my guess you need
to bring you need to bring a sacrifice Did you do it with
me?
No.
We're just put, put.
Okay, I'm trying to find the server, you guys.
After I find the server, I'll set it up.
I'll set it up so you guys can see everybody talking.
I don't think we're going to be able to, I don't think we're
going to be able to see each other in voice chat.
Oh my god, I got, I just got 20 frames in that bush.
the fuck was on
W Bush W Bush you shaved your bush back to going southwest
guys I'm so hungry I'm so hungry thank you Mr. Herrera I'll
be going now you were talking to the Herrera that freaking
killed Doki bro he said I could eat because I'd paid the the
the toll what's the tall the tall guy he had like nine
bodies there and he was like you paid the toll which was
your friend's life so you can eat for free and then i ate i
got perfect diet and then another guy came over and and he
was like you think you can eat for free bitch you gotta pay
the price and he was like what's the price he was like a
life and then this other guy came over and he goes that's my
friend and he just killed him and he goes now you can eat oh
my god
Being Herrera is fucking awesome.
Why are we not that?
All I said is I got perfect diet.
Thank you for your sacrifice, Stokey.
Bless up.
No wonder you didn't want to splash slate.
No way you used my life.
Dude, I didn't want to waste it, man.
I want to waste your life.
How do you sniff, by the way?
I haven't been...
Cute.
There's no way you're asking right now.
How do you sniff?
So that's our end for us.
How are you like the best fucking rivals player I've ever
seen and you don't know how to sniff?
She also is the longest living dynamite.
The longest living dynamite.
She doesn't know how to queue.
Because you guys all sniffed for me, so I never had to use
it.
Yeah.
But you know what?
It's good.
You're a natural born killer.
You gotta love.
We gotta leave you.
You gotta figure it out.
You gotta live for the next 10 minutes and then 20 minutes.
I'm so hungry.
There's no food around me.
Find some food.
Sniff around.
Guys, food.
I'm sniffing.
It's a dead food.
it's oh this guy probably like entombed or something what's
in oh like the that's an alligator boy I mean it won't help
with any of our diet but it's food fuck it I've smelled
nothing it skins it alive I mean dead I don't think it has
anything this has diet for us it has everything we want to
eat I don't see anything oh I see it wait I'm him bro I have
not smelled a single thing yet.
You have to keep running, bro.
Like, Doki, worst thing that happens, you starve to death,
you spawn closer.
Best thing that happens, you find food, you grow, and you
learn how to play.
You could also just drown yourself.
I am next to a river.
You gotta try and live.
I'm next to a river.
It's not letting me drink anymore.
I'm swimming.
I think we already like took all the organs out or
something.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
said it had so much diet and it just didn't give any well
i'm pretty sure it's because we're too small oh i got some i
think it's because we're too small to like take out the
stuff because he's so big what's
the grass trail like it says i could forest i think i'm
about to grow big oh that makes you hungrier don't eat that
oh okay we can just chill like little stones you eat that
make you hungrier why why would anyone do that different
proteins it's good yeah because if you like have a full
belly but you need better diet you can eat them and then you
get hungry oh i see slash me lays down right here wait wait
for stripping wait where are you what's up next to you we're
uh we're at the bend so anyone know if i'm going the right
way yeah we're at squiggly river Twigly River, the Soul
Water one?
Yeah.
All right, sick.
Yeah, I'm just hitting this last PZ.
Yeah, we'll just wait here for you.
I'm at South Puddle right now.
We found a dead Dinosukas.
So we're just eating it.
I don't know if I found anything.
Circle of life, bro.
That's what killed all of us.
Well, I'm pretty sure what happened is they either entombed
or, like, stored it.
Oh, they probably entombed, yeah.
That's...
Oh, wait, there's a baby triceratops over there.
There's something.
Yeah.
We could kill it.
because I can't find why but it says there's why right here
oh no I'm gonna I'm gonna jump this guy I don't know where
we I am slash me bleeds it my food why did Annie hiss at it
I don't have food still guys because I'm gonna time ever
since i've been like i'm the only one role playing as an
actual dino you're too you're too small to take out the
organs yet and i think i'm about to hit a growth spurt if so
if you wait a bit i might be able i'm too ever since i've
been left on my own i'm just gonna starve yeah all the meat
that gives no proteins or anything okay guys can we rp can
we rp can we be dinos wait over there after I dude it's easy
you say gully but we've all fallen on hard times bro it's
hard to just get back none of us are parents anymore we're
all just baby we're all just trying to live dude and you're
bitching about RP bitching I've never been to my life can
you give me a break can you call me some slack why can't I
be in there before there's so much grass around me but you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna grab a drink I think I'm gonna
starve I haven't found a single body if the stand still and
hold cue for a long time yeah don't be moving and doing it
that one it won't be good also your best bet to find food is
the little trees on your map you run over there and that's a
sanctuary and usually that's where people are fucking dying
or you could kill someone yeah i sniffed for a while and i
couldn't sniff anything there's like no sanctuary go to the
trees on the map the tree yeah they look like a little palm
trees and you're little compass oh I don't have any oh I
have one they're so far I have to go backwards why is that
why is that it's not a trike it's the thing that isn't a
trike why is it just sitting there the dibbles yeah it
jumped in blood a dibble and he went across the river guys
wanna start well he's probably trying to get stop the bleed
it takes that long to stop the bleed yeah it's a while he's
kind of he's kind of invincible when he's near the water
against us yeah but he knows that the second you get in the
water he's going to kill you if you just try and swim over
yeah yeah exactly that's why i'm not you done this i missed
it i'm not there go babe i'm at squiggly river why did you
leave her all right we're so well i can't cross it because i
died if you sniff you'll see you died again like b y and
stuff that's where we are earlier run a dead Dico, like a
deep dino, you know, super sea.
I think it's over for me, guys.
It probably didn't in tune.
It probably tried to do the saltwater run that they do
that's like really dangerous.
What is it?
Died of dehydration.
You think so?
This thing is really big.
He's going around to the right of us.
It's just what the guy doing.
I don't know.
I'm running up on him, though.
What you doing?
I feel like I'm running this direction.
forever no I'm not trying to square up when you're on the
water like that he's saying you're trying to square up dude
he's he's squaring up on me oh you're like how do you how
you walk everybody was the moment I've been left alone no
food no water no one to love me oh are you good no it's just
grass why was I born a carnivore how many jumps is it for
the jump mutation oh my stomach adapter die i'm back here i
crossed this river before you guys laughing at him he's got
bitched wait how do you die i'm starved posture like he was
in alpha and the guy like fake charts are okay oh and then
gully puts it up where am i it's a little oh is that
stripping go where am i that's a little chicken looking guy
that's a herbivore i'm still alive i think oh i'm alive i'm
alive
this way
oh i'm running north up those swigly river yeah you'll see
you'll see us i'm heading towards West Pond area.
Wait, West Pond.
There's still nothing near anything.
No, no, no.
We're like below West Pond.
We're like still in the squiggly river.
Yeah, yeah.
That's why I'm.
Does nobody want to like fucking die?
So you see that?
I'm going to die.
You see that little...
You see that little like heart in squiggly river?
Natural selection.
That little island.
It's a cycle of...
It's a circle of life.
Yeah.
I'm just part of it.
Yeah, I know you are.
Yeah, we're right there.
I see the dibbles you're talking about yeah there's just one
dibble he ran away anything anywhere rock right now oh oh
doki update I'm in the palm trees but I found zero people or
food I might die soon my stomach is growling I'm you'll be
fine you're learning though right really i'm sniffing not a
single body or soul i'm still not able to eat anything from
this guy i grew up can i eat bees you can try i want to try
and kill that guy over there jumps across oh i see your bees
and honey
wait gullibles I'm trying to cut them off gullibles are you
guys on the the little you're on the same landmass as the
heart thing right uh yeah we're we're running back we're
trying to kill a guy real quick that's right if you sniff
you should see all the like dynasukas parts wait there's a
meat over there but what where follow your nose doki follow
your nose i'm following you we're near the we're near the
heart on the map now all right cool squiggly river oh my god
i found food oh it's a rapture i'm i'm a cannibal well
that's okay that's okay it is what it is if it's easier we
can go to west pond wait how do i know i'm a cat oh it is i
literally see you running around I'm really it was three of
you right four of us yeah can you see me down the beach
south of you I see you oh my god we're back together I'm
temporarily infertile from cannibalism but my coming is full
now all right let's go to West pond I'm thirsty anyways hey
guys have I survived 10 minutes look at my scars already
have i survived i think i survived past 10 minutes now what
does 10 minutes mean you guys you guys come pick me up yeah
we're coming now heading to highlands all right i'm going
northwest nope southwest southwest i'm going southwest
all right we gotta go to west pond or pygmy i need water
yeah I also need I think I'm going the right way my diet I
wish I could eat the dynasukas parts but it's bugged
off I go oh yeah I got hydrate too let's do a quick little
sniff check see if there's air around
I hear dylos probably that same one that fucking killed us
before wait I see I I smell food on the one day one day i'll
meet my pack guys just you wait they miss me let's see what
died here is there a hera oh no oh okay i'm okay i know guys
they missed me hanging out of a tree right oh oh oh oh i'm
okay i'm okay who's getting some stam all right wait and see
guys oh no wait oh no yeah i made it car parkour no it's
pretty if it's probably a harrow if you had someone wait and
see guys i'm gonna meet up with my pack i'm gonna meet up i
got a little bit of food time to head to the pond guys don't
worry they miss me guys they all miss me they're man i do a
mistoki bait in our pack careful i've killed people on this
exact lake as a hera yeah but if you stand right here it's
like the safe spot that's exactly the spot i killed yeah i
was a prime hera the only one that can drop you is the tree
opposite us and you could see them coming yeah they're just
they're very homesick over me
guys we're a team it is a european server or like australian
because i have 100 ping stripper is probably driving wait
this is a european server it says at the top right i have
112 it's not yeah it's not european oh i got 30 ping dude
yeah yeah you're thriving it has to be east coast right no
no it's eu it's it's eu 100 wait you're in eu yeah i'm in
england you're in england You didn't know that he's written
in England.
No, I did.
I thought he was American.
It's hard as fuck You don't know big stripping I don't know
for some reason.
I just thought you live in America You're not big strip man.
I used to yeah Like six years ago.
Yeah, I still have six years knowledge.
I'm six years behind You're stripping has like a like his
own animals and shit now.
Wait, what you own a farm?
Yeah, I own a farm.
Oh shit.
What kind of animals do you have fiber at that farm?
I got yeah, I got fiber All over the whole farm.
Damn, you're living the life.
Damn.
I got six sheep, two pigs, uh, two turkeys, ten chickens.
Ten chickens.
Like, do you eat the chickens or are they for eggs?
They're for eggs.
Whoa, hey guys.
Friendly?
Oh, hi, cutie.
Hey.
Friendly?
What's going on?
I'm like, I lost my pack.
I'm dead.
Guys, I'm dead.
I lost him because I died.
And fucking Ben say that when I was playing with them the
first time.
they told me to go northwest or southwest i'm just saying
i'm just saying wait no no no no it's cool no i survived
making it to highland surely i have to go to highland do you
guys know where highland is yeah of course yeah stop is when
i'm looking at the map do i just go up the mountain we just
missed yeah yeah yeah between directly where we're pointing
just go which one do we Cool.
My raster friend said to wear a stegosaurus, but you guys
are cool.
That's what I'm saying.
Most of us are chill.
Nice!
I'm just getting like ones along the way.
Don't go to Highland.
Yeah, we should go save, Doki.
Wait, I don't go to Highland?
That's true.
Don't go to Highland Sanctuary.
That's what I was trying to go to.
Oh, okay.
All right, let's go.
How do I know if it's Highland Sanctuary?
What percent are you?
Um, I am...
Hey, Doki, how are the friends you found?
They're good.
They're good people.
Are you having muscle chasms?
Um, maybe.
I accidentally ate one of my own kind because I was
starving.
You know you can't hit prime though, right?
Yeah, I know.
It's alright.
They can be prime and they'll protect me.
Bro, she really is saying accidentally ate my own kind when
she knew what she was doing.
She's like, bottoms up.
I'm gonna eat this.
No, she just saw a meat icon and then ate and then after it
was like...
Thanks guys!
Bye!
I hope you guys don't get eaten!
What kind of dinosaurs are they?
They were stagosaurs!
They were so nice!
you guys said they hate us but they're so nice i mean it's
the triceratops that hate us mostly also the stagos see that
you're a little baby and they were gonna adopt me they were
like you can't us like no i'm just trying to find my family
who didn't abandon me all right i'm i'm heading to the
mountains good roll gully that sounded freaking epic dude
that was terrible is this where they pointed oh no that one
did they did you ask them for directions oh my god no you
asked for directions you have a match and they were pointing
they were pointing with their noses i'm worried like oh
you're like if you go that way with their nose you get to
highland i was like thank you how's everyone sam looking
should we have a quick rest stop to my toe hey this is i'm
looking at my map right now all right let's take a rest
right now let's get everyone full oh no the map the map
thing you said of where am i
who's who's gully talk wait the map doesn't isn't showing me
where i am anymore it should be i paste my cords
where the am i that's screwed
oh you're wait she's almost to us just go straight west wait
where are we right we are a little bit below sanctuary okay
so we need to go north and then yeah if she goes west we'll
meet at the highland lake okay i just need to go straight
west the highland link where we all died last time all right
is it up this mountain it's west you can go around the
mountain okay can kill babies in this game too oh yeah you
can dude i can hear the dilow still by the way okay maybe we
shouldn't meet at the highlands lake then you're the you're
the dot on the top right where the dot on the top is the
bottom left okay how about how about we go to jungle pond
where i'm what where's that find okay jungle pond is
directly south of you okay but i kind of want to get the
highlands okay i'm going south now we we need the migration
zone though for highland do i go we should run north touch
the migration zone and the pz and then go to jungle bomb
yeah yeah i go south all right i'm going you can either go
south or just wait there wait where i am or go south either
either or you know uh uh i'll wait Chuck, I'll go a little
self and then I'll wait.
Yo, we're proud of you, though.
I survived, guys.
Yeah, you survived.
We're doing awesome.
We're proud of you.
We all proud of you.
I did.
He won't be prime, so you're technically a loser.
But other than that, but I'm alive.
Oh, yeah.
What if you guys die before you get to prime?
To be a loser than to be dead, though, right?
But then you guys will protect me by being prime.
I think I hear it to your Rex.
Where are we?
Did I hit the PZ yet?
Not yet.
I need to go a little bit.
All right.
I'm going to chill.
I'm chilling here.
Ben, this is my chords.
I'm going to chill here.
Oh my god.
I trust Ben more than I trust myself.
How have you not learned how to make the map yet?
All right, let's go to Jungle Pond.
I just trust Ben more than me that's one way you're in a
good spot just stay there we'll meet you there all right
cool guys I think I'm doing really well in this little bit
northwest of jungle I'm running over there now I'll rename
it I'll rename this stream I couldn't do it because I was
busy trying to survive it's drifting around this mountain
Danny's really taking this RP thing real far that she
doesn't even make noises anymore or say anything she's
silent accidentally got kidnapped into being a dinosaur
there you go every time I go near her she like snaps at me
like there's a hierarchy where you think she is in the
hierarchy that's fine we can chill here until until they're
here to pick me up above gully i'm also let me honestly
contend this game is the whole stream thank you for the
super chat lally thank you thank i'm just saying like you're
probably above gully james bond got reincarnated into a no
killing anyone in the pack you have to pin pin to establish
dominance it's okay guys they surely they me right oh i
heard the little like wait i heard that wait i heard that
too wait you guys are close to me yeah we're right next to
you oh hey guys i'm hungry you guys know where food is no oh
oh where did you guys go wait i saw someone next to me wait
there's a little guy right here get this guy Wait, where are
you, Ben?
I don't think we're catching that guy, man.
You serious?
That guy's fast as fuck.
I'm catching him.
The only way we catch him is if...
Oh, I'm catching you, bro.
Wait, where did you guys go?
I heard that.
I lost you guys.
Oh, yeah, I heard that.
I stopped chasing.
I'm worried.
You should be, like, a little bit west of you, up the hill a
bit.
Okay.
I heard.
i'm gonna go pin him so oh i lost you guys do you guys hear
this guys i'm bleeding now i have to take a little rest real
quick who pins you uh gullibles was like telling annie he
was trying to establish dominance yeah so i made sure i
pinned him first i made sure i pinned him first i hear you
guys but i don't know where you guys Oh, I hear the grass.
Hello.
I don't know if that's a good...
That's a...
That's me.
You're hearing me for sure.
Have you moved at all since you put your coordinates?
Yes.
We're on server one.
Yes, I have.
I'm in a bush right now and I'm here I'm here Ben I'm here
Ben I can't hear in no ads talking in game isn't she me
should be like right on top of you no you're not yeah okay
Just in the bush.
You like my cannibalistic colors?
Yeah, man.
Thanks.
I hear the grass.
Throw his fucking hair back.
Ben, where are you?
I swear you're like right here.
Can you come out of the bush?
Is this...
That's a tree.
I'm out of the bush now.
The building?
Oh!
Ben!
i don't know building oh it's too cool to like sit facing
the way we do gully you have to like fucking face away i did
it i found ben oh my god guys guys i found my family whoa
he's so intense i found my family guys are you guys back
where i left you like up on that ridge yeah we're on a ridge
and we're just sitting is there like food nearby well i'm
gonna starve this soon do you guys have food guys look it's
great though see guys i told you they wouldn't abandon me i
told you guys i knew i was important to them guys i knew it
i know it was important guys i'm here we're a full pack now
Yeah!
Yo, what's that?
Yo, you made it!
I did!
Wait, how are you guys roaring?
I want to roar.
Um, you press your three muscle.
Wow!
Wait, how did you get...
Your three muscle!
Wow!
How did you become all white?
I took the cannibal mutation, which turns your whole skin
white.
Wait, you're a cannibal too?
Well, no, but like, I'm a cannibal where, like, it's
actually good for my diet.
no bad wait should i be accountable well i only did it
because i wanted to turn white so you want it to be white
yeah it looks cool
and i should get yeah so i was the opposite of gully guys is
there me nearby i'm a little hungry no we're gonna have to
go find some food a little dokey it's okay i know how to
queue look at this i know how to smell guys Ice King, you
ready to roll out?
We gotta find some food.
Wait, do you guys have STEM?
Does everyone have STEM?
I'm only a little STEM.
What are you doing?
I'm ready to roll out.
I need time.
I need to sit down.
Ben and I had a little adventure.
God, see?
And my family!
My family!
I did it!
I'm at 56%.
I did it, guys.
How do you know what percent you are?
Press tab and you hover over the growth bar.
I'm at 52.
Does that mean I'm like...
I'm never going to be prime, am I?
Don't say that about yourself.
Don't say that.
Just follow your dreams.
actually no you dc'd so if you want to be prime we're gonna
have to go to a sanctuary real quick don't we chat we always
die in sanctuaries I mean if they want to be prime like a
little bit yeah just a little bit but what if we lose
someone I don't like your negativity I'm not it's not
negativity and get you guys prime we need to hear this I
don't want to hear this what if what no okay We need to
practice CBT.
We need to practice CBT, okay?
Close ball torture.
Cognitive behavioral therapy.
We need positive thoughts that manifest into our life.
Sash, what are you guys saying?
Yes, bro.
Well, let's go.
All right.
Doki, you have Stam?
Yeah, Stam.
Guys, look at that.
We're a team.
Are you trying to bite people again?
We're a team now.
Wait, who?
I heard like someone nibble that's me I have temporary
muscle spasm because I was a little bit of a cannibal
earlier just a little bit it was the only me there I was
dying
guys guys you saw what happened you saw what happened guys
just a nibble just a little it's an accident
All right, if you were if you were stranded in Mount Everest
and there was no more food except your fellow climber What
would you do?
What would you do?
Tell me
Oh, you guys are so fast.
Don't worry.
We're gonna get you guys your sanctuary pro
I would starve.
Oh, so then you will both die.
Yeah, you starve the other guy would eat you think about
that people in the back can't hear me
my god they're so fast i'm just a little guy i'm a little
guy i'm so slow sniff check hey stripping you don't have to
do the slow walk from normal trotting you get sam in the
back too i'm fucking role playing can you get off my bed my
bad my bad seriously there's like no integrity right now any
food i just wanted to fucking RP walk.
That's all I want to do.
RAR!
People are going to hear.
People are going to hear us.
Why don't we want them to hear?
No, we want to be silent and we want to flank them from all
angles.
But then like, we can establish our dominance.
We'll establish our dominance when we ambush them from the
shadows.
It sounds like... We'll establish our dominance when we're
all in prime.
that's true see the strategy is we send one person forward
and then everybody goes left and right why is there like a
why is it focused on the one person they see they don't see
jungle music it's a clever girl strap man it's the clever
girl oh i see i see stealth
i'm not very good at stealth guys i mean you survived all by
yourself that's true
Sorry, I got a little jumpy.
I got a little jumpy.
I ate a raptor before.
I have temporary muscle spasm.
Can Doki Raptor go in the front?
No, no, it's okay.
It won't happen again.
We're gonna get lost.
It won't happen again, I swear.
Oh, my legs!
Guys, I've accidentally fractured my legs, but it's okay.
I can still walk.
I'll go get them.
Oh no.
I yell.
Guys, wait up.
Yeah, then pick up.
A little bit.
I actually, guys, I might be...
I might...
Thank God they don't practice survival the fittest, right?
Guys?
That's a good thing.
There's no natural selection in my pack, guys.
It's a good thing.
You're welcome, guys.
Careful, don't run too fast on it.
What is going on down there?
I'm so freaking excited to be a dinosaur.
Oh, God.
Hey, guys.
Are we going to find meat soon?
Hashtag what that means.
No, they can't eat meat.
They can't eat me because of...
and my fucking ear right now they can't eat me because they
want to be primed her legs she used to rest how who ran off
a ledge no way i'm hobbling no way i'm hobbling all of me
i'm hobbling all of me come lay down on the bus that's not
hurt it's okay i want to be part of the pack
in the tears so I can be part of you guys.
I'm spamming jumps so I can get my jumpy twitch out of the
right of the way.
I'm going to go over broken fucking limbs somehow.
Guys, did you guys know if you jump while you're running?
There's a potential that you can fracture your leg.
No shot.
What?
There's food far far northwest of the east.
Here are you.
That's all you can breathe.
You just want to be part of the pack.
Roar!
Oh man, I look so cool.
It's okay guys.
Everything will be fine.
Dude, did you figure out the map shit?
Me?
There's a...
There's a website.
No, I'm talking to Mew.
Oh!
The map?
have to be yeah we're we're in right now we're rolling i
can't see anything it's very dark press x oh press tab click
asset location put it in wait why is it saying i'm not
connected to mumble excuse me i probably kicked you for
being um you might need to enable the plug-in if you haven't
done that because that won't be the run of the litter
anymore guys oh spigot guys guys i'm runt up the litter
anymore guys there's gonna be a one there's gonna be one
more frontier than me is it this is it guys guys i'm i'm
starting to starve yeah i'm in all right press tab asset
location click copy put it in the discord i'm gonna sniff so
any food we can bring i'm a little worried yeah i'm gonna
starve soon i'm at like a sliver of hunger okay you're in
the northern jungle when mu gets in tell her to exclamation
mark id and then you do exclamation mark invite id that
number what what we can look for some food and bring it back
thank you i really be honest we're not gonna find any oh
yeah it seems like we're pretty far
I'm gonna stay because I still get a rest.
So how do I know if I have special audio now?
I'm sniffing.
I don't sniff any food.
I'm sniffing, guys.
The food.
Surely the food will show up.
What's your hunger bar looking like?
Like, it's like 1%.
I see a little bit of whiteness in my stomach.
Huh.
Maybe you shouldn't have broken your leg.
I'm so sorry.
He's talking to you like that.
It's okay.
It's all right.
You don't have to take that from him, you know?
Yeah, but I'm just a little guy.
I'm just...
In this world, there's betas and alphas.
We're in this pack together.
Really?
You won't leave me behind, right?
Yeah.
behind for food out here oh wait there's some food right
here see you guys see we're a family no this is a family i
will not be in a mo omega it's my exploit invite this is
just like a piece of invite id that all right
ben did you find food one piece of food i found one piece of
food too where did it go where did it go but I think it
disintegrated in my hands.
There's another raptor in that bush.
Wait, what?
It disintegrated in my hands too.
Wait, it can do that?
Well, we know where the food is now, so...
Oh, okay.
Wait, I can hop a little bit.
Uh, he's about our size.
Where?
It's tripping brought one.
Did he?
He isn't his...
Or sure, if we're dead.
It's right there.
Oh, it's this?
Oh, I can see it.
I see it.
It's this.
right here right here dude all right I'm leaning yeah rally
cry rally cry okay yeah definitely me you teleport to rain
yeah it says she doesn't have stand okay she's press H and
lie down until she has full stand do it okay so limping I'm
kind of cute oh yes okay then to keep resting until you're
not olympic i was eating though i had to eat
look at that guys yo where was that raptor you saw everyone
is trying hard to protect me as the little guy look at that
see you stem into the claw my family loves me yes press h
and just lie down with those four yeah i'm just laying my
family My family loves me!
I've known it!
Was that one of us?
Oh, that sounded a little bit imposing.
Uses Doki Raptor as a shield.
Oh, I should hide.
I should hide in the bushes.
Yay!
But, uh, my family... I knew my family.
family loves me guys soon man yeah I might like half I knew
it that's pretty I'm pretty fucking hungry I mean if we run
to Delta yeah I might run ahead shit done stuff uh those two
are spawning northern jungle well then they can just go
south and meet up with us yeah we need we only have 20 to
hit like all the migrations into PZ we need we should
probably hit everyone in Delta Did you guys hear that?
Yeah, no, it's still screaming over there.
I was gonna have them hit the sanctuary at Verdant Pond.
I know sometimes Delta causes crashing.
Oh, it's not good.
Do you think there was a fight back there?
Maybe.
I just take so long to heal.
guys it's okay don't wait for me do you know how to make a
splint can you get like two woods and like a piece of string
well let me yeah let me claw this tree yeah yeah i'm
temporary and fertile and i have a fractured leg that's okay
temporary and fertile.
Let's go.
Alright.
No kids, no problem.
Yeah, no kids, no problem.
You don't want more of my genetics passed down.
Alright, let's go.
Make sure they're running so.
Yay!
Now I'm starving.
Now I'm hungry.
No fracture makes, though.
all right i wonder why there's a black i guess like the name
didn't load in so are you when you're up yeah i'm back dude
you are so back i'm guys i'm just not gonna jump anymore do
you know that do you know that your your bones feel like
better and stronger that's true that's true what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger but i think we're also majority
of us are starving right
Whoa!
That's a T-Rex.
That seems like a full-grown.
Do you think he'll be friends with us and then take us to
food?
No.
Fuck no, babe.
What do I talk to?
Is there any way to kill myself in this game?
Whoa!
Exclamation mark slay.
Can you stand still?
Thank you!
Well, exclamation mark slay has a 30-minute cooldown, so.
Oh my god, I almost died there.
That's okay.
Use it wisely.
What's the problem?
Why can't you?
because we're not brand new because we both spawned in with
no stamina.
Darren, you don't you don't spawn in with no stamina.
Well, we both spawned in completely zero stamina.
I'm going to invite her.
I dodged.
Water.
Gotta drink some guy hydrate.
Yeah, hydrate.
Did imagine a crocodile just ate all of this?
That'd be awesome.
that'd be pretty funny i would bat chest who would be who
would play as a crocodile though i feel like that'd be
pretty boring because all you do is just swim yeah but then
you ambush people and then steer the out of them yeah but
it's just like what else do they do in this game other than
that crocodile just water you're probably yeah you're a
crocodile you're a loser respawn in life and be a better
player
I'm close to starving too.
I don't know.
I think Mew is like one of their friends.
There's a lot of stuff happening over there.
What the fuck?
There's a T-Rex.
Whoa!
There's Stegosaurus.
Whoa, they're fighting.
It's like a brawl.
There's a Teradactyl watching.
Wait, is that food?
Do you see that?
there's also a dino oh my game crash that's really bad my
game crash too i think we i think we all looked at it and
then we all crash that's the only unfortunate part about
delta is the crash chance is very high is it settings
related i don't know i don't think so i think it just
happens i gotta i gotta turn off like the global elimination
stuff anyway my up was that delta yeah oh it's just delta's
like a hot spot of people oh i see i mean we saw a lot of
people there oh fuck i have to do all the pz's and stuff
again what's it we were one right yeah yeah i'm connecting
bro we've got 20 send to redo everything it's really quick
if we just run back but we don't have we're all hungry
though it's not that quick right because we lost we need to
re-get perfect diet as well um no we don't have no perfect
diet's fine it's only pz that get reset okay rain teleport
to me you guys are already good luck wait oh we just crashed
right oh you cosh how come they're not they might have i
mean they are a lot of people probably did crash when we did
a server thing i think if we just run oh my client to west
rail and goes down then we get it my client disconnected and
you guys this seed yeah if you crash and you feel like wait
for your guy to be like out of the game ah i don't just oh a
lot of people like got out of the game so i'm pretty sure a
lot of people crash there there's like fucking every every
single one of you is just afk standing here still we're so
lucky we're so lucky we were on this side because we were to
all go killed did you not crash i did i just got in really
quick oh so gully's in as well as well i'm still loading we
just if we go we can we can get it real quick stripping we
just have to go to highland get those four pz's and then go
to west rail and we're done yeah the problem is though i'm
starving Oh, me too.
I need to...
Oh, I'm red right now.
Delta real quick.
I'm red.
Yeah, but...
Wait, we're not in a group anymore.
No, we have to review.
Oh, wait.
Somebody got food.
Is that food?
Which out?
There's a crocodile coming.
Well...
Run out of the wall.
Wait, what the heck is that underneath us?
Yeah, no, where is this little guy?
But there's people...
Are you looking for food?
Are you looking for food too?
I'm looking for food.
Wait, I see some food behind us.
We're so hungry.
Wait, we could jump that guy.
He might be giving it to us.
Okay, bro.
Wait, kill that guy.
Wait, are we supposed to group up again?
He's running.
He might kill us, dude, but we could take, we could try.
We didn't do it!
We're a team!
I just want to say hi.
I jumped him!
Whoa, I missed my jump.
I'm biting him.
Oh, shit.
Make sure some people get bleeds on him.
Yeah, I'm bleeding.
I'm left clicking.
I'm just doing pure damage.
I'm just biting.
Yeah, hold left clicking when you get on him.
Wait, Ben, why?
Did it...
Wait.
Why are you just...
They wouldn't let me move.
Laying down in front of them.
Wait.
Like, I jumped on him, I jumped off, and it wouldn't let me
move.
So I try to lay down.
but why would you lay down like there because I could not
move is he dead you still alive no he's alive but he's
bleeding Wow he's bleeding so I had a good hit on I had a
good hit on though why would you just walk up in front of
him I didn't know I was in front of me I didn't know I No!
Well, you can spawn with Ben, Doki.
Ben, can you bite me?
Yeah, you can...
I mean, if you just run up behind him, he doesn't really
have any counterplays, kicks it too slow.
I'm not starving anyway.
All right, post your coordinates once you get them.
And go.
I died so Ben wouldn't be lonely.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
okay we're doing yours we we don't have to do much we can
just play this slow just don't yeah just literally don't let
him rest that's it yep i'm surprised he's not talking to you
guys some people don't talk in this game he was talking he
was i didn't hear him say anything oh yeah activities when
we get you a shoring gun right type this word into your chat
Yeah.
Dude, I don't know why.
It's like I jumped on Gully's back when he was on the Raptor
and it's just like, he froze.
Hello.
Are we close to them?
Uh, we're pretty close.
I think he gave up.
Oh, nice.
I can't tell.
Just go to sleep.
Give me food.
We get to eat.
All right.
Tear this guy up.
Oh, okay.
Why are you jumping on me, you dumb mother?
fucker like brother in christ sorry i had to i had to uh i
had to assert my dominance you're trying to usurp the the
alpha position is he bugged for anyone else wait who's this
small hop in did did did
how far are we from them ben uh we're pretty close you're
the small one wait i'm not cannibal anymore on the right
wait who's this tiny one all right there was like there were
like two other raptors next to us that were like oh i'm
looking for food they just showed up when we crashed i don't
want to invite the small one and let me i'm gonna be honest
boys i i'll be honest boys i took the cannibal trait for
this reason if you want me to take that little out do it i
mean you do it if you want do it do it eat them i don't give
a hoot eat the kids
we can't get it i've been getting like bits and pieces of it
well we're close by you bit me instantly on first meeting
and now i'm bleeding out i didn't know that was my bite
button man i mean try to right we're trying to get it man it
is floating
you've been spam jumping no you can bite me back sure maybe
like once
oh did that fix maybe like one time all right full stamp so
something happened i don't know what happened i know i
jumped only one time you should take that person out
stealing our food we're gonna end up on the other side of
the river where all the oh well wait maybe they'll be our
friends you try but you seem very happy oh i'm so hungry oh
why can i eat all right let's go i have some it's a stamina
no okay i wait yeah we fucked this guy up though look guys
you're all so nice to me we have to be finished eating we
should like that on a mighty roar look guys i'm not the
right guys they care i got full i'm full on eating now i'm
good i really need a
We're a team.
You don't have to redo a perfect diet.
No, but I just want it.
Oh, it takes shit.
I filled up on why.
They love me part.
They love that I'm in the pack, guys.
They all care.
Well, I'm ready to run back towards Highland and redo the
PBs and stuff.
All right, I gotta go.
gotta go i gotta go i'm like half goodbye that'd be good
yeah that's why we can go do we have to walk or can we run
because my stomach keeps going bye-bye are you jumping why
did go sometimes go don't jump right i don't know something
came up and you got to go tomorrow i guess maybe he had to
poop man yeah where did go he just insta left he just he
just ran went i gotta go i gotta go i gotta go yeah it was
okay
you think he intentionally died on that one spot so his body
would glitch out wait did golly die no that's the whole
thing oh he just left left okay
all right yeah let's let's uh let's get these pcs before
it's too late man yeah i'm just resting i'm getting my
energy back we're gonna have to trek it should be easy okay
if they're leaving we're gonna have to look for food okay
I'll smell with you we can go wait what the hell's happening
over there betraying him wait during the party where that
person is gone don't smell anything who's that who's that
person that just betrayed him I don't know.
You can kill him if you want.
Well.
You want to betray your own kind, huh?
Is what happens.
You become evil like me, bitch.
Why did the music change?
Just those little things.
Why did it go Tom and Jerry just now?
All right, my Sam's going to be ready to go.
Tom and Jerry music.
You ready to go?
movement stripper yeah all right let's go and he's still two
years yeah oh how far have we been from them uh well they're
running away from us currently because they don't care about
us and hate us want us to die wow we unfortunately just need
to get the pvs and stuff again oh my god someone's stalking
us we should have the delta migration zone
yeah we should get two more just to be safe yeah i'm gonna
get highland and west rail all right i recognize this place
well i say a big pyramid that's not really like dinosaur
core it's a Jurassic Park this place is an experimental
island yeah I see they're running humans soon as playable oh
really humans have the humans already but they're buggy wait
would they be like hunting the dino's down guys well kind of
the humans are going to get like jeeps and guns and shit oh
yeah but like the the humans are locked to first person and
they're like really small compared to dinosaurs so it's
basically a horror game when you play the humans the humans
eat other humans i don't know dude i i think they should let
you be born as a baby and have to grow up how do we drink
wait but who would take care of the babies then someone has
to who takes care of the baby dinos that you gotta figure
out just start a toddler with like a start a toddler pack or
something shit you know oh how about you get adopted by the
dinos it's like
oops there's supposed to eventually be different humans
there's modern humans and cannibal tribes and drink less
because i wasn't sure like crossing land how bad it would be
with adino why did you hear that ben there's people here i
heard someone talking earlier behind us we could kill him oh
we cannot kill shit you need little babies if it's another
baby you can kill it yeah we kill him he was talking he was
like confused just like me that's okay can get the scraps
from the battle we saw earlier apparently t-rexes are
supposed to be changed too what did it change in t-rex well
right now t-rex has like a charge into like grapple that is
just insta-kill for anyone that's a little bit op
that's what happened to me yep yeah they have charged into a
pin yeah and it like breaks every bone in your body when
they pin you oh that's hardcore so then you can't run away
apparently so we drank water out of like a beach and now
we're both really sick and throwing yeah because you drank
salt water oh that matters what are we supposed to drink
there's lakes yeah you should go to the ocean and then drink
salt water and be like huh i don't feel very hydrated yeah
we're dinosaurs wait it was a lake though yeah there's yeah
there's yes it was there's a lake there's sand looks like it
should be fresh water but it's not this is a literal lake it
has sand it's a river connected to the ocean if you look at
the map that i linked earlier you can see that the entire
area see it's not just me The map isn't intuitive.
I'm starving.
They just don't know the map exists, Stokey.
Your problem is you don't know how to use it.
I know how to use it.
Why are you using a map?
It's kind of a medic.
Ben is just better than the map.
I'm using the same map.
He's better than the map.
Ben is using the map.
But he's better than the map.
He's like a GPS.
I just went straight west.
Straight west?
Straight west.
Can't wait for you guys to catch up.
got 10 more we got plenty of time i'm gonna cry out like
fucking four four pz's here oh yeah i'm just gonna keep
going into west rail and i get those one you don't do the
ones north of the lake nah we're gonna starve west rail
should be fine it's just no food anywhere nobody's dying
okay there's a billion food everywhere oh we have a battle
that was heat i love when ben was like dude there's just no
fucking food anyway this game sucks oh there's a billion
food everywhere because we just got to the place with all
the food we killed their baby there's a baby you go to the
areas with food there's fruit yeah so this lake has a
waterfall going in it if you go to the top of the waterfall
and drink it's fresh water if you go to the bottom it's salt
water oh i've been just downing salt water they're in south
plains i will grow and kill all their babies that's fuck so
you see that corpse in front of us yeah we're gonna go
snatch food off it and run away oh wait cuz you fell okay oh
shit express G on it yeah the my tummy is full of yummy salt
water now well technically there's a secret mutation where
if you drink enough salt water you can drink salt water as
if it is fresh water i'm yum yum yum yum i don't eat it it
just oh okay so we do that again yeah all right guys i want
to pet ferret first they're really stinky they're cute but
they stink yeah you can remove the glint no apparently you
just have to feed them better no they're like they're like
yeah also like is it room is removing them inhumane or is it
okay probably fucked up it's like declawing your cat yeah I
don't think that's the same he's thinking your ferris he was
declawing your cat yeah yeah this is fine if I eat here
right yeah it's I feel like nobody's gonna come over they're
on the other side of the T-Rex where I left is there What if
he's cool?
Might as well drink some water then, I guess.
Don't get my stand back.
Cool.
It's pretty sick.
Nice.
Get my stand back too.
Oh, I jumped off the waterfall.
12% left.
I'm good.
Swimped off a waterfall.
Yeah, but I hit the rock.
So you're dead.
No, my legs are just a little broken, but I'm okay.
She has a fracture leg.
I told her to go to the top of the lake, the waterfall at
the top of it, to drink water, and she somehow ended up at a
different lake.
Alright, so we run southwest.
We hit that PZ show forward, then we hit the nursery, and
then we hit all the west row PZs.
Oh, what do we do?
We're going across the bridge.
That's the playout leader, Sonny, this.
It should be fine.
Ben and I are so safe.
you guys are wondering we're so safe we're so safe thanks i
believe you guys yeah i believe you guys can survive
crossing the bridge if something come if we see something at
the other end we start right um there's there's two
dinosaurs on the other end i died at when i got jumped at by
a hera all right fall flight here tonight uh i feel good
yeah yeah it's good enough They feel all right.
Do you hear that, Ben?
I do hear that.
I don't like it.
So we're just going to keep running.
Hey, guys.
I don't like the sound of that.
Dude, come kill us.
We're right here.
Hey, guys.
Friendly.
It was a little stego in another.
Don't shoot.
They didn't.
It's okay.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Sound like a couple of fucking herbivores A couple of little
baby chuds I don't sound like Omni raptors at all We're
gonna kill you It's like little babies It's a giant
triceratops She's everywhere
Can we eat berries Or do we need to eat someone Or a
carnivore I need to eat meat That's what you get for cheese
I'm so sorry Carnivore That i really suck at swimming man oh
my gosh oh the tree this tree is so big for no reason
i'm just trying to say hide her neighbors straight west from
here why am i oh where are you guys are you see the this
goalie's basement flooded oh again i think i'm drowning oh
that's so ass how we how when was the last time how how did
a basement flood that's why he was he just disappeared all
right so we're kind of right where we met doki earlier where
you guys have it you can go to highland lake or southwest it
was like a year and a half ago their basement flooded and
that would have flooded again oh where are you guys we all
we're just leaving Highland to head to West Rail.
We're just going to go touch the crash and then hail the PZs
in West Rail.
And then we can meet up again.
Yeah, we're like, we only have 10% till prime chance.
And we go like...
We'll meet you in a bit.
Alright.
Does he, does, does Gully live by himself?
No.
Oh, it's just him as roommates?
Yeah.
Yeah, they probably met, they probably ran over and was like
basement flooding and he was like, go, go.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
That's fucked.
And how far are we from them now?
Pretty fun.
Because they're literally running away from us constantly.
You don't like it.
We got to do what we got to do.
We want to prime.
You got to get their prime.
Prime is very important for being able to kill big stuff
like a T-Rex.
Would you guys protect Ben and I after you prime?
With how that last fog went and how both of you died.
ben was a little bit unfortunate you on the other hand it
was my first fight you have the survival instincts of like a
toddler it was my first standing in like a triceratops mouth
earlier yeah but he was friendly he was friend he said the
guy we're literally fucking mauling is friendly no no not
that the triceratops yeah he was chill we're literally
mauling this person you're like guys i'm gonna get a bite in
runs in front of them I'm dead.
It was my first fight I was learning.
Be careful because there's been T-Rexes hiding in bushes
over here.
We have to go north to get to the crash, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm running through the crash right now.
But I'm just saying as we run through here, be careful.
Yep.
Because there have been there.
There was a two T-Rexes fully grown camping and hiding in
bushes here.
Fully grown.
They played more than 15 hours of T-Rex.
Oh, that's Dylos, dude.
Fuck.
I'm just running through the bushes and...
Isn't Dylos the one that give hallucinations?
Yeah, and they're the only dinosaur that's fastened us so
that they can just fucking kill us so easily, dude.
Wait, that's so OP.
Yeah, but if we get one jump on that...
Oh, my God.
Careful, careful, careful.
Almost rationed my leg.
Oh, there's the D-Los.
Oh, they're all babies.
We can kill them right here.
how long does it take for them to get below me you want to
kill these guys yeah i was just i had to touch the brush
it's one full grown and like two babies oh wait are these
baby t-rexes oh i think these are baby t-rexes oh oh man i
fractured my leg did i not touch the take a break the I
don't know.
I normally run until I get stung by bees and then I'm like,
that's good.
Yeah, I didn't get that.
That's my fault.
That's so weird.
It was a weird slope.
You guys died?
No, I fractured my leg.
My ankles.
It got twisted in a direction I didn't think it was
possible.
I think I saw three baby T-Rexes.
It blew my nose, guys.
I'm going to mute myself.
I jumped.
I didn't even realize I jumped.
No, it was the cliff.
Green has a go.
We found a guy and he took us to a big old T-Rex that was
dead on the gun and now we're not hungry.
I think I got it.
My screen was really red for some reason.
It's because you're almost dead.
Uh-oh.
You should lay down.
It was the cliff, guys.
Also closing your coordinates so I can tell you where to go.
I think you're going to have to be going northwest if I
remember where you were.
Man, it would have been so juicy killing those baby Rex why
didn't you kill him you want to kill that guy over there
that's a dialogue yeah we should all right I'm ready there's
like a full-grown and one baby oh my yeah I don't know how
guys I thought this was gonna be a quick game I'm sorry
wait what's up run run run run you want to play the aisle oh
wait wait yo be cool be cool brother no i'll pay by you 50.
i was just like i'll put yeah sure i'll hop up yeah sure
i'll hop on before stream and yeah he killed me bro no no no
no no no god are you dead are you dead yeah i'm dead we are
both of you dead no no no the other dude i'm so surprised he
didn't attack you were pinning something though and just
jumped me for some reason i wonder where the fuck they were
hiding fuckers i think they just ran up the path man wait
what killed you guys or what killed stripping uh four-sized
allos damn didn't even say anything or just it was no no
they just rolled up man it was i was like i'll pay pay you
50 dog and he just didn't even respond coward just like nah
fuck these guys all right don't worry about me man finish
the mission sure for it be the prime that we all want to be
finish the mission big dog i'm gonna finish it go finish it
for me i will you gotta prime it up for all of us we wanted
to get revenge on the fucking dillows and then those wait
did you at least kill him uh i don't think so i think he
stayed around that he must have let out he must have let out
maybe also those guys were breaking server rules how so why
you're not allowed to third party unless you're either yeah
they break the or era yeah they break the rules then yep
wait that's what it is man oh you're not allowed to third
party no i'm at a stamp so i need to reach it oh but like if
it's a group thing then it's fine like the group counts as
one party yeah yeah if you're in a group it's that's
honestly that's probably why they skipped you and hit me
yeah because i wasn't actively in the fight yeah oh
that makes sense yeah what do you mean can't third party
what does dog server well you have to you have to remember
that oh what the how did he know i was there i might have
followed your footsteps or maybe he heard us talking yowch i
still have fractured leg but i'm no longer wounded that's it
i'm not in the rush yeah they're like 80 it's just sure four
left anyway wait oh my god is annie fucking dead oh annie is
dead i watched your name please just disappear
I'm freaking dead.
Dude, great.
Why is it only me?
Great death try, though.
Run away like a little baby.
Thank you.
Oh.
Run away like a little baby.
Am I wrong?
Yes.
Yeah.
The only reason Shreve was alive is actually because he was
the only one killing something when they showed up and they
didn't want a rule break.
So they just killed the rest of us.
oh i was also responding that one chatter i'm pretty sure
they have the no third parting rule because there's over 400
plus people in the server so if you could just third party
all the time then yeah it'd be kind of fun no one would it's
more about like intention like if you're just intentionally
third partying like that's no one would initiate fights they
would just try and third party people that were weak wounded
oh i see and then it would be fun also my legs better one
after everything's finished but i mean stripping and and
anne can can invite each other because they just that's also
why that's also why hara is awesome because you can third
party wait you can third party is wait why is there specific
rules for different dana's so like for alligator and hara
your ambush predators yeah you have to third party yeah well
not even that if you're like sitting on a tree and they just
so happen to be each other yeah like they're in your area oh
like it's your territory yeah grab me uh 53 803 it's okay as
long as one of us can prime all of us are technically grand
i died can someone kidnap me you can join in you can join
stripping in can i be an omniraptor that's yes you're on you
were supposed to be okay good wait what were you before
stripping where are you guys we're in uh near the pit down
south are we heading the shirt for are we heading to the
babies um we're gonna head to strip work because he's like
my id is five three eight nine five can i get kidnapped
please oh i gotta get going any can you invite her and
should be on cooling oh it's like i'm fine i'm fine i'm okay
i'm okay so we got attacked by allos and then i think annie
died to something that wasn't a nano yeah what did annie die
to i don't know i think carno it i think it was an aloe that
chased us maybe how close were you how did it find us wait
sure for how close were you were you to prime i'm not dead
but how close are you to prime uh very close i'm at 71 oh
yeah should be getting it soon there it is i found those p
rexes all right we need to go to the crash let's go this way
because you're in our group
okay my shervor gets big and strong he'll protect all of us
guys snipers roaring on stream to hear if he's close.
I don't think it's a stream sniper.
I don't think anyone would stream snipe me in this game.
Especially It was a carno that killed me.
That's why I couldn't outrun it.
Yeah.
He was headbutting, I think.
Damn.
Where the carnos have like a charge or something.
Do you check for feet?
C.R.P.
Alright.
I can't smell.
Where are you right now?
We're about to enter West Rail.
If someone would streamside me in this game, that's some
dedication.
I smell food over here.
Oh my god, he...
Nice, it's close by, too.
Wait, it just did a corpse clean up.
Oh yeah, never mind.
No, it may happen, surely.
They've not done it yet.
Oh, it's here.
Can I eat this?
Yeah.
I keep one worried as a fellow rafter.
It might.
If you ever see it, like, A, B, or Y, it's not a friendly
Rattler.
Yeah, so A, B, or Y, it's just neat.
What is A?
It's just not saying.
Stripping has been stream-sized before in the eye.
Oh, constantly, yeah.
But...
Whoa.
It's a lot harder for people to do on this server.
They have to register, set up mumble, like, all that other
shit.
We lost you, Striposaur.
We're just on a normal server.
Oh my god.
I have a body on me.
You see that?
It's like stuck on me.
I don't see.
I have like a bone stuck on me.
I still don't know how to do the intestine heart thing.
I think I'm fucking it up.
It's tap G.
And then we'll start like tearing off pieces.
Yeah.
But this one I think might be out.
Oh I see.
Be certain.
Just tap it?
Yeah, there you go.
I picked it up out of your hands.
I can see a little dino up ahead of us.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Very carefully.
I want you to right click me and then press space bar and
jump off me real quick.
I jumped.
Okay.
Thank you.
Moment of truth soon.
need to heal too why do you need to heal i don't know the
full-size oh it's because i auto fought back i think it's a
hair actually fuck it i'm going oh we climbed up the tree
run run away back to healing run to the crash you guys okay
over there on the other side living our best lives one day
guys one day we'll we'll be a pack again guys hey we were a
pack for a bit and then we killed that herbivore we just had
two uh casualties and then another casual thing another
casually happened is good how did you let them die sure for
how did they die no how did you let the hell me die uh we
got ambushed so you have the plus i mean that's that's the
plus we're ready to go mine is like yeah that's still me
I'll be fine I believe hang on there do be some raptors
raptors are pretty squishy is the only unfortunate part of
raptors we just have to be together yeah what the fuck is
this a full-size T-Rex dead in here maybe he entombed yeah
in the crash yeah I don't know because entombed give the
plus yeah or storaging just drops a dead body there's some
gamma somewhere that smells yeah it's over here yeah man all
right come on in one more percent until the moment of truth
all right perfect tap g on this thing until you have like
don't fill up on food but tap until you have like in things
are looking at intestines in your is this an intestine
things that look like It's a super string.
All right, let's eat this then and we'll get the hell out of
here.
Once you two are full up.
I'm not.
Oh, putting this away.
Why aren't you guys praying for my death?
That's not intestine.
I'm not, bro.
I want you to become the prime.
That's a super string.
No, I was talking about my chat.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you have a good one.
Rain is also praying.
Yeah.
Everything is just regular meat.
all right let's go team yeah it takes a while to get oh oh
my god it's just meat for days i think i'm just grabbing the
same meat piece over and over again if you're not big enough
you can't grab certain organs like you have to be the same
size this is yeah it's a tiny little thing
okay Holy shit, this guy has so much meat.
Shit, I got the bugger gun.
Yeah, are you ready?
I don't.
We're going to have to...
I'm just going to re-log.
We don't have to wait for it to bleed.
So I think that's still...
Is that meat?
That's just meat.
I'm going to eat it, though.
We need to...
We need to swim across.
Still meat.
Holy shit.
at least I'm healing all my blood while I wait give
me a heart oh I got a heart do I just eat it the heart will
be B and then it should be like the next couple things
should be the intestines do I do I just eat it do I just
omit yeah it didn't go up wait my well you if you press
enter and then hover over it you might be sinking oh no it's
zero wait 16 for sure now you just need at least one percent
oh i got yeah it's okay oh you got the intestines nice eat
them up eat it right maybe as long as you're not full maybe
we should wait no okay just carry that in your mouth until
you're not full anymore and then eat it oh yeah i already
have already have your diet weird how that happened all
right i don't
okay let's go dude me and annie just crossed the river and
then me just sank to the bomb and died bro what is the
survival ability of you guys wait bed you guys group up so i
can find you oh my god five percent it's 0.5 oh my god oh my
god oh my god you might have to drop work you're gonna have
to drop the food no wait until it's just yeah it's just just
follow me i'll i'll walk all right just try it along you
just need like a little bit of open thing on your bar if i
don't get it i'm gonna be pissed but i should get it sure
for will protect us there's the bridge again it's okay
different bridge you're unprotectable doki you literally
just run into danger and that is not true that is not true
i've lived through a lot every every death in the most
pathetic way ever every death i get stronger i learn from my
past oh okay i can eat it now um okay what'd you learn last
day um i'm at 22 percent for for why if you press tab to say
perfect diet under status report lost us you learned not to
stand underneath the heart when i was full i think because i
don't have anything is that your location is that your new
location oh that's okay we can find you beta before you run
yeah Why do they keep posting the location in Discord
instead of just looking at the map themselves?
I'm just going to do this.
Because we're not cheating like you.
Yeah.
That's the map.
There you go.
Nuh-uh.
I don't know how to read.
Wait, wait.
Did I get it?
I got primed.
Wait.
Find us, surefore, protect us.
All right.
Where are you headed?
Okay.
I want to see how big he looks.
Sure, fellow.
I mean, he's going to look normal size because he needs to
actually grow first.
Is he not fully grown yet?
He's been on there for, like, years.
He's only 75.
Do you have the jump one?
No, I'm prime.
I should be bigger now.
Now, your normal size now, you have to grow another 10% to
get the extra bonus of being prime.
You won't stop growing till 85 or 90.
Reduce incoming damage when fighting larger species.
I think I get one shot anyways.
Wait, I forgot to select the mutation this entire time.
Careful, Annie.
Careful.
Wait, give me a sec, Ben.
I'm selecting a mutation.
Is reduced stamina, rejection, regeneration, threshold.
Who is the?
Let's get it with that.
Yeah, I'm good.
I won't get fall damage now, Ben.
actually let's might as well get the it's five percent even
that good though yeah we can get water at the pot now in the
biz in the biz we call that death we're just gonna oh we're
gonna go around them there's the one where you heal when
eating that's always a good one oh that's enough to shout
out one though oh it's so good though because it was so OP
for a Sarah yeah couldn't you fighting, you just bring a lot
of meat with you.
Wait, I don't even see that one.
Where do I go?
Take less damage from bigger dynos is pretty good.
Movement-related mutes?
I don't see any movement ones.
Well, we're going to be fighting bigger dynos.
When we're together, we can fight a T-Rex.
And double-check where we are.
All right.
Do I need a pygmy's puddle?
Are you closer to West Pond?
Give me a sec.
I could do a hyper metabolic intonation.
The less hungry you have, the more damage you deal.
Oh, yeah.
Or just straight up do like more damage to bleeding targets.
It's pretty good.
Yeah, but that's just 5%.
Oh.
That's crazy that Ben and I have not bumped into another
dino for like the last 20 minutes.
she jinxed i don't see anybody there's no way anyone is here
either one i might as well just get the oh i hear people see
hello oh my i could just rest a lot i mean no we're pack
tactics so i don't really need a gamut
oh it's so dark that makes bleed stronger it's crazy i don't
think it meets the bleed stronger just makes you do more
this place is so dark then press x i i did but it's still so
dark yes get cannibal and eat gully unfortunately gully is
going to cannibalize by mr pal yes can you post your cords
please um it's a t-rex i can That's a T-Rex where?
That's a T-Rex roar.
Did you not hear it?
Oh, no.
I recognize it from Jurassic World.
More damage.
Prime Raptor.
Alright.
So where'd you say you were, Ben?
Pygmy's Puddle.
Pygmy's Puddle?
I'm at West Rail.
Why is that?
It's raining really hard.
It's just a cow.
The E heals you.
Oh, I'm pretty close to you.
It just allows you to be healthier a lot.
Like, say you finished a fight, and then you eat the person
you killed.
He took some damage.
Or he passed you, but you never know.
What?
He did?
I cannot see shit, not gonna lie.
It's okay, that means they can't see us.
All right.
Drink it.
Is that water?
I didn't...
Yeah, I'm not next to water.
Oh, there I am.
I don't know how you can see that as water.
I just followed my sniff.
Oh, you were smelling.
Where are you?
Let me try sand.
I see now.
What's dark now?
Say it again?
My car is by a crash.
What's the progress up there on Strip and an End?
Hey, you're right.
We're sure for us.
Right there at Pigme's Puddle?
Rain was basically where you are.
It's in West Rail.
One side of the West Rail got a run.
Oh, it's in the other at Pigme's Puddle, though.
That's where we're going.
Yes.
Me and Dave Keir are at Pigme's Puddle.
Rain is north of us.
Were there, too?
I didn't even realize.
This is where we died.
I'm sure we're better.
Oh.
To the aloes.
I want to go on the rock, actually.
It's safer in a bush.
Um, oh my god, I was stuck there.
It's definitely safer in a bush.
It depends on the rock.
There's some pretty tall rocks.
Should we get on that rock?
It's the rock that's chasing us off.
I think we just make no sound and hide in the bush.
Wait, you're a pygmy's puddle?
Yeah, we're on a pygmy's puddle.
I'm, we're, I'm literally on the beach, the squiggly beach.
We have a nice Yeah, we're gonna wait for sure for to get
here.
Yeah, we'll be a pack again Then we have to find me Yeah,
where you at?
Oh, you can see these dragons
Yo, this prime rabbit I posted it
She's from the east side of Delta.
Yeah, good luck Just keep going less Guys, we're going to
meet up with everybody.
Wait, me?
Yeah, you're going to be a family.
We're going to be a family.
I can't wait.
I'm at the point.
This was so long.
Let's see if we're drinking from it right now.
Jump's on your murder suit.
Wait, is he here?
Is that ice cake?
how big are you i'm big wait stand next to us i want to see
how big you are that's an adult ben it's a prime bro holy
these double our size yeah i'm a prime dude bro he got prime
bro he's got he's not even prime size yet that's a regular
at all bro he's got cred he's not prime size till he's like
85.
see you guys coming 85 years old to be prime yeah we're
coming to picnic spot right now all right wait how did you
get out top of the rock oh my god he's okay you jump but
you're like big like can i jump that
am i forced walked i'm hungry wait i'm like forced into
walking how do i un z oh there yeah
i just don't have stamina my game decided it was time to
close i'm gonna rest a little bit you went to delta delta's
the crash area but also a very fun area to be if you don't
crash that's a little freaked up i think like as like after
you crash you can stay in delta but like sometimes you crash
there it's just you look at them right and then it happens
and i gotta rest i want my chat said that apparently at some
point in the game's life every time a hipsy would spawn it
would crash people's yeah a what spawn a hipsy what's a
hipsy hipsy's like a little bird her before that spits at
people oh so playing that character crashes things well i
don't know if it's still a thing i'm just saying it wasn't
uh it were it wasn't the hipsy in the last patch it was the
little penguin guys oh the penguin yeah every time they
would grab a fish in the river in doha it would crash
everyone in the area that's dumb yeah
it should be right here somewhere uh usually for pygmy's
palm i just sniff and see the water oh yeah you hear that
here what right all i know is i'm very hungry and i need
food behind this those are raptors pouches on you all right
nice i'm gonna go north and wait who the fuck is that wait
they're here is that rain yo oh hey hey guys we're all
together again almost well except for me almost back in town
i had anti-cheat it hit me oh just try again yeah this It
just means that you're still logged in.
I'll go north.
No bad.
Are we all following Cherfork?
Heading out north.
Yeah, but we need stamina.
Yeah, I need to rebuild stamina too.
You guys can get some stamina.
Just go north, scouting.
That's right.
Look, we're babies, Annie.
We make them do the work and then we come get some food.
Come get some food.
We make Cherfork kill everything and then we come over.
I see two giant T-Rexes in front of me.
You can take them.
You're prime.
if you guys were all prime with me i would take your prime
you can take them hey omni raptors are pack animals i need
you guys we can beat it as emotional support how many
t-rexes are over here is this four t-rexes are they full
grown they're supposed to like not be pack animals no i
think the side the group limit for t-rex is like three or
four maybe six or seven there's a really big wall here if
you have what are the babies for anyway in this game did you
just say what are the babies for in this game yeah eating
what's the point kill them and eat them every time you spawn
you're a baby what do you mean no i meant when you have yeah
yeah yeah yeah well when you when you breed you pass on all
your mutations to the baby so they get extra mutations oh if
you go into if you go into the mutation tree and you see the
little hexagons around the sides they're the ones you
inherit from your parents ah so i don't need to be the baby
next or you can also get those from entombing what but if
you if you lay eggs and nest and like get a baby to a
certain like level you can get prime from like having kids
also if you're born from an egg is you skip one of the
things needed for alpha requirements here oh so it's Better
to raise children.
Yeah.
Maybe you can't.
Well, there's a mutation you can get as a female where you
don't need a man to have eggs.
Oh, wait, what?
Yeah.
So you can just...
Okay.
Oh, so like the lizards.
You can be like, I don't need no man.
You just...
Yeah, you could clone...
You're cloning yourself.
Dude, we like ran through the legs of the Rex and the Rex
was like, oh shit, little baby.
And then he goes, no, it wasn't.
And we just kept running.
Well, you guys running through their legs?
Yeah, we run through their legs.
We didn't see them until it was too late.
What the fuck?
Would they be able to crush you?
Because it was in the dense jungle, man, and we're like a
foot tall.
We're running through all the shrubs and shit.
Can a T-Rex step on you and die and you die from it?
Yeah, they can.
Oh, I see you.
Damn.
Team Brazil, by the way, sure.
Team Brazil has been screaming the last seven hours.
He's lying right now.
Damn.
the fucking world cup team or yeah the world cup team yeah
they've been screaming the last seven hours they've been in
that not for soccer not for soccer i was about to say dude i
don't think world cups can scream but i told my like rivals
yeah yeah they they want to be the top two wait you see that
thing over there yeah what's s4 i'm north wait where did he
what I didn't I said I'm going north looking for food
because I'm about to be fucking starving There's something
along the road here There's a motherfucking baby T-Rex It's
okay.
You can win that you can win that you got this he scared me
so I left if the baby If it's a baby baby T-Rex is like one
of the weakest things in the game Yeah, but he was scary and
he was running at me really fast and he had tiny arms And it
was really intimidating.
It's like a magic card guy to say he's a magic car on the
road I could kill um I don't know I don't know he's a magic
car it's such a good good I'm I'm he really is dude he can't
do shit I see him I found him he's over here well you found
me yeah I found you all right they was looking for you
coming over stripping I've hit everything I need for for uh
Prime just except perfect diet that's all I need yeah we're
about to go to the sanctuary i'm sure there's gonna be a lot
of things to eat over here we might have some more
casualties let's find out maybe it'll be me we can't lose
you you're about to hit prime i already am prime wait you're
an adult yes i hit 75 oh you're no prime till 85 dude then
fuck around oh i already have the prime mutation i'm already
yeah yeah but i mean like i want to see what a prime prime
actually looks like the weight difference between a prime
regular one is nearly double it's crazy i i weigh 448 kg
right now damn you've been packing bro i weigh a hundred i'm
like where am i you can like throw me around and i'm 256
right now all right guys we're going into the danger zone
everyone get ready don't worry we have sure for it to
protect us you're unprotectable we've already no no no no we
have sure for it to protect We should probably protect him.
He's kind of more important because he's already prime.
That's the staggers in front of us.
You can't put...
Yeah, what's up, guys?
Hey!
Wait, I know them!
Are they the couple?
How's it going?
Well, actually, I don't know them.
I'm just chilling.
Yeah, just some rafters.
Yes.
You're not prime, are you?
I'm prime.
No, we're not.
Yeah, just one of us.
That's kind of offensive, man.
Just implying that we look small.
a matter of what you can't even tell yeah well no he was
just talking to me because he knows i'm the big lad i know
yeah yeah yeah but he's saying that you look small to him so
he can't even tell you guys full on your group and no no uh
almost almost i'd be careful i heard there were some carnals
around here or something it's allos actually they're fully
grown allos yeah there's like a group of three they're like
murderers yeah they murder anything inside they don't even
rp they don't they don't have the rp let them know i just
want to warn them what did they try rp rp to like kill them
sniffing that's a big ass t-rex oh my god i only see bones
is there seriously nothing over here i mean there are those
two stegas i mean i see a bunch of dead bodies down yonder
work that good we could only kill the sagos if we're all
prime but sagos are like some of the best pvp dinosaurs wait
then why aren't we what oh hey what's up guys hey guys i'm
just going to pass a little raptor in the bush hello we're
just looking for some lunch oh a baby t-rex oh there's a
fight right behind us if you need hey he just kept saying
please please it wait there's a food here why don't you want
to eat the food here i wanted to but i saw a baby t-rex so
you know i had to try and kill it it was right behind and
then he went please please please though i don't know how i
didn't jump him i was spamming right click on him everybody
be very careful there could be anything hiding in the bushes
as i say wouldn't something try to kill us right now
potentially but there's a lot of us let me eat let me eat
there we go What is this?
Oh, Karnos!
I'm on him, Ben.
I'm fucking him up.
Oh, I have bees on me.
Oh, I have really, really bad news.
Oh, no.
What happened?
Whoa!
Wait!
Can you fuckers pay attention?
I heard bad news!
I got scared!
Literally the survival instincts of like...
hey what's up everyone i'm hiding a bush i'm hiding a bush
there's no way like i say we're under attack and doge is
just like hey look at all these herbivores i'm getting
attacked wait i got distracted it was like something bad
happened i was like oh no she's not even with us who cares i
was concerned i was concerned i have i have empathy she's
kind and she has a whimsy and happiness I was concerned
about it because she's alone.
Your kindness almost got you fucking killed.
She was alone and I was worried about it.
I fucking died there, honestly.
Wow, that's fucked up.
Anyways, I died again.
See, then you're gonna fucking respawn with me.
No, wait, wait.
Then we'll both be lost because we both can't read the map.
See, Ben, I saved you.
Am I closer-ish?
Can I chill up here?
I'm healing.
actually you know what you're gonna check copy that code go
to the oh ben finally got tired of pasting for you she's
should i should i kill myself i can't do anything about that
no just run north and then the west once you're uh north
side of the building
okay on this map is there something i'm supposed to look at
that's just kind of lying oh my god there should be a thing
like close something or something hold on how am i supposed
to understand the map if mr cow doesn't understand copy
paste press the magnifying glass That's true.
That's true.
Press that.
Sorry, blah.
The red clothes in the top middle of your screen.
You have that?
We need to know, we need to know where you are so we can
start going in that direction.
Shurpen, watch out.
You got two bogeys inbound.
Oh, don't worry.
I can give you my coordinates.
Shurpen is next to me.
I'll hide next to Shurpen.
taking it i'm just trying to get testins out of this thing
all right i'm plus right now for that perfect diet yeah hey
wait i can probably get it out though i don't know does it
say it has intestines in it i mean i just am and i didn't
get so i don't know whatever i was eating earlier didn't
have any hey big guys are they friendly there's something
behind us all right why do i me man seriously they ate
everything that we had man yeah that's that's bro if there's
one with intestines i can rip it out for you but it needs to
say why and watch out that's a baby t-rex they just lunged
at ben wait till that right there a little pussy
oh no always kill baby i got it lots of conna we got him we
got him coming over We're helping.
Did you get him?
Yeah, we got his pen down.
Nice.
Yo, get me some, get me some intestines out of there.
Do you want me to take out these intestines?
If you can get them out of this, uh...
Hide right here.
Nice corner.
That we just killed right here.
I'm re-getting.
Actually, I think I can get it, maybe.
I got a heart.
I got it.
I got the intestines.
Who wants some?
intestines i do rex rex oh my god you guys are big jesus you
guys been growing how long you guys been t-rexes all my life
damn you're so good you're so those guys literally those
guys literally did the spooked up bit i put some intestines
on the ground whoever hasn't gotten y for perfect time i
don't wait i've even got a y before but do i need a like get
it until you only need to get it once oh okay i just need a
heart i i also got some why i put oh you saw a heart here
you go heart two heart that's on me all right i got it heart
tab that was that t-rex definitely like he allowed you to
win whoever oh that's me it was me yeah i think it's both of
them it's because they're massive you went rar that was good
yeah that was good see that's also why it's fun to play like
donasukas or something like you're chilling in the water and
you can just jump scare the out of people people just be
like this is a great little cliff for raptors by the way
perfect diet nice there's like a perfect cliff for us now
you just need all the zones wait i'm somehow a perfect guy
i've never gotten to be well you might know even if you got
like even if you got like point one percent it still counts
you only need one and then we're dead oh yeah one percent
great oh my god look at this cliff man we can see anyone
coming from here oh and it's a crash behind us so big things
can't sneak up on us there's no way they'll never know we
can ambush them you look at this squad imagine if we were
all primed you exactly we all have time we almost had three
primes until the incident happened yeah the incident we just
need to we need to get better at running when we're not
prone the incident was literally here wasn't it they fucking
went down it was a little bit down that way but yeah yeah i
remember it was like yesterday was the baby t-rexes is that
a baby t-rex no they're the allos there's so many of the
aloes we can take revenge on the ones that killed us should
we get the one in the back go in the front oh my god oh oh i
fucked up that But Chud Prime fell off a cliff and if he
didn't have the spam skill, he would have actually died on
impact with the ground.
Yeah, quite literally actually.
It's insane.
You fucking Leroy did it.
I'm so used to playing Harrow where I actually have like
jump distance and height.
I feel like these guys can definitely just sneak up behind
us.
We're really gonna let them...
I see something directly ahead of us in the bushes.
It'd be really hard because they have...
Oh, I see that little thing over there.
you see the whole guy hey go get it hey go get it i have to
re i have to regain my stam all right i want to go get that
just careful for the allos because oh they're running he saw
you he's running back i think it's a baby t-rex no it says
sarah oh we'll kill wait annie it's it's over here it's on
us yeah i'm not gonna kill you don't have to kill the child
be a pussy why are you saying don't be like don't be a pussy
but you're just fucking sitting here well i never said i
wasn't a pussy i know he all right i kind of need to go get
water what do you say what do you say you got you said
something about if you kill this little sarah what are we
not we can't kill this little sarah because of what yeah you
can no they said we can but like hit me out though what if
we killed them no no no no if you guys are damn we're god
we're good oh okay he's saying we can kill him but don't
kill us oh
i see if we if we were bigger man i'd say we just get these
two off right but we we got a lot little guys if we had like
three or four primes we attack we got we just gotta be
patient man this is why we keep losing we just don't let
everyone grow we just gotta chill out yeah yeah we're too
bloodthirsty we gotta chill out there's why over here this
is our crib you guys think we have to get everyone their
pz's now oh most people i mean i took i took annie through
like seven and two mz's i don't think i took any of them or
dokey know what's going on with no no i don't i'm looking
for water you guys think i'll hit prime probably not but oh
i mean we can go the war is straight east of us rain there's
a fat lake yeah there's a huge lake we should probably go
together actually i'm running that way because my wires are
straight red now we can either make sure people get primed
by going back to west rail or we could go somewhere new and
try and get it through like northern jungle i think we go
northern jungle and like uh damn experience something yeah
yeah yeah let's go to the lake get some to a dillo die to a
dillo at the lake and then we'll go and then we'll respawn
as babies in north jungle and we'll try and do it all over
again guys that's the fun part well that's the fun part
about this game because when you have long ass and you're
killing a bunch of people you're the one sending everyone
back to babyville yeah yeah once if we have a full-grown
pack of raptors even if only a half of us at prime it's
that's gonna be so scary for anyone the way that you guys
going a pack of something so no that pack ben means it's a
bunch of mixed dinosaurs together oh so like we don't we
like us as a pack we don't appear on that radar but if there
was like stagos around us and tricerat yeah if we would
change like those two aloes for a while then we would have
the icon yeah oh yeah there's a guy just in this bush here
you're right you literally just ran right past the way i'm
pointing oh there's wait is that a t rex it says something
there's two pat two sayers what you're doing in that bush
man sure hope you don't fit in there we can see you you a t
rex i haven't seen a single alligator on this whole server
dude i saw it it was up there at the delta no before we
crash there's one chilling on the bank yeah i reckon it's
they might be because they like go rid of the fish spawns
maybe it's really hard to grow well this server doesn't have
mpcs yeah so there's no fish to eat how do the the
alligators eat they just hope they get lucky and people die
on the riverbank i guess and that ain't fun why would anyone
want to play the alligator thing in that bush i don't know
it's giant it has to be a t-rex though right i just saw its
little tail sticking out of the bush oh did you kill
something no i'm gonna i'm gonna get off so i'm just gonna
store it for the night all right sure sure we love free food
thank you guys don't attack them don't attack basically what
happens what'd you say how many refugees are in your group
that's all of us six six i think six we have one more on the
way that keeps dying i'm over i got a red raptors stored
over by um damn lake that's an adult that's weird well it uh
it gets loaded in wherever so i died again oh yeah it
doesn't save the location that's good i only hear people let
me let me play a song as i go a song i killed myself
I hope the T-Rex just comes in.
No, I think the T-Rex might have been logging out.
I don't see him anymore.
That's full.
Four is the nicer cool.
Three is the angry cool.
Well, I'll try and make my way up over here.
You guys stick around the highlands area.
I think we're going to North Jungle.
Oh!
Goodbye!
If I, if I, I'll try and make my way to North Jungle then.
Yeah, if you see us, let us know.
Thanks for the meal.
What's your name?
I ain't no worries.
I'm Ice King.
Ice King, okay.
Rusty, so.
Nice to meet you.
How does it feel watching your friend get eaten?
You want to join him?
Damn!
Oh, damn!
How's it feel?
Well, we're both both died.
Hey, I think we just chill here for a little bit, man.
We got some more.
We got some food.
Hey, there's some more Y here if you guys need it.
Oh, I need some Y.
I need some Y.
It's the intestines.
There's T-Rex over there.
You think they're gonna come over and eat their food?
Where that Y at?
It's the intestines.
It's right here.
Okay.
Our luck is turning around, guys.
Docky, this is when we eat gastrolis, docky.
Oh, wow.
To get hungrier so we can get more buffs.
That's true.
Oh, I see how that makes sense.
Yeah, but we don't have any here.
Oh, wait, we do.
Yeah, we do.
It's right here.
We're eating them.
Am I?
We're working through here.
Yeah, press tab, and it'll say ingesting gastrolis.
Oh, yeah, it does.
And then we just wait.
That makes your hunger go down faster.
so we can get more oh i see wait are they joining our pack
are those two stegas now we'll be long gone oh yeah no i
just i just said we're going this way if you find us where
you find us but i'm not but they were so nice though they
were nice but if we start letting people in man you know
what happens man every time no what he was saying is that
he's so the reason they're dead is because they stored them
on the server so like they can just come on these guys
whenever and he's like oh i see a group of raptors i have a
raptor because of mine bleeding so oh so because he wants to
store his raptor we didn't even tell us the way he just said
if we're around this area when he gets here yeah but we're
not we plan on leaving no i just i literally just told him
i'm going north jungle if you find us you find us some b
that's a heart right i think this is b right here Do I need
to keep perfect diet?
Yeah.
All right.
No, you just have to have it once in your life.
Okay, I already have it.
I have a great diet now.
The reason you want nutrition on the other ones is like one
gives you higher health regen.
One is like lead resistance and I don't know.
And the higher you have like all your buffs, the faster your
growth rate.
I see.
153% growth.
Yeah, it's insanely good.
I'm at 97%.
I'm at 0%.
being nice or weakness you say it's being nice or weakness
yeah as a raptor yes but what if like the stagos protect us
dude don't you feel like you would have so much fun being a
fucking herbivore Loki
no I love being a carnivore baby you'd have so much fun as
being a fat little baby triceratops wobbling around give me
a sleep prompt and i'm logging out people are looking after
you that's true i could be a i could be a carnivore so the
thing the thing doki would enjoy is if she was a full-grown
prime stango and you can just walk around like you own the
place but how long does it take to get there a long time
like seven hours eight hours oh i feel like we played i mean
four hours already we played wait no we played like almost
seven hours already we played five hours already yeah I
would have been a full-grown stego smaller creature well you
would have to survive till then and with your babies today
go everything kills you we played stegos for like a couple
hours and then the t-rex just came and one shot me well I
think when we were playing I was at like 50% yeah it was I
was coming along and then I was really tired so then I went
to bed i don't think it was a t-rex i think it was an aloe
it was a hundred percent the t-rex gravity and slam into the
floor so i'm good dude nothing could go wrong now nothing
could go wrong we're gonna just eat get fat and grow as a
family i would say don't lay there next to a bush where a
t-rex could just yeah i'm laying about far back over here so
i can see something coming oh wait i should come back
because you guys also have to remember all of these a b and
y's are very juicy to other carnivores they don't know they
don't know we have that smell that is coming over for sure
bro i can't even smell it how do you smell it i'm having
cute we can probably grab like we should bring some of the
organs over here maybe oh we can also move the organs and oh
i see it never mind i see the a b wise an ambush I feel like
they'll see us there.
We're not really hidden.
Not from over here.
We're like in the bush.
We're not really hidden up here.
It's foggy though.
Did imagine if a Herrera just top-roped one of us right now
from that cliff behind us?
That'd be awesome.
I fucking love Herrera.
Next time we do this, we gotta do Herrera.
Oh yeah.
Which is tomorrow low key, right?
we have world cup tomorrow yeah yeah world cup tomorrow how
you how do you two both have the world cup we're both on the
same team we're on we're from the same country we're both
canadian yeah we're both canadian yeah dokey you don't sound
canadian at all i sound just like sure for what do you mean
what are you talking about i sound just like him you're
right what am i talking
pro pods are reducing my yeah they doing yeah i am a little
hungry now i'm gonna eat another bite
fish yum yum yum dude it actually looks like we did this i
feel like people will be threatened by it comes over and
just sees a bunch of raptors in the mist in the back and
sees all these these two bodies is like oh my god they kill
two snagos those raptors are crazy we did imagine not having
x-ray and then the lightning flashes and see all of us
posted up like you see our glowing eyes or the glowing eyes
don't think we're all prime little do they know well they
can tell by you small chodes i can't tell no way i think
we're pretty big wait what percent are you at rain uh press
tab over the bar 60 51 57 where we're gonna wait where's the
percentage at zones i like how you just said press tab and
hover over the bar and then right after you go oh 61 you
said where the fuck is me you did she just give up she's
died like five times i'm trying my best she can every time
she spawned the bar bottom right five times in a row oh my
oh no it's okay i'm like not kind of close but i'm almost
this is what happened the first day we played when we know
about the tp command so the entire play session was just us
trying to meet up there's a lot of mountains yeah they see
was lit though true the euphoria finally being with ben as
he's limping across i thought it was gonna be nice to be
when he was like you suck how long did it take for you guys
to fight you don't know what hell i went through playing
vintage store with mu there's no way of being nice to that
creature vintage what what i vintage story hardcore
minecraft i miss vintage story yeah and then the ice king
just abandoned us and said we're losers and just didn't log
on and then our freaking kingdom went to poo and then mr cow
didn't feed us anymore so we all starved and our dogs became
increasingly inbred because we left them alone for too long
i should log in and kill them please don't hurt them please
i still care about them though yeah but they kind of got put
them out of their suffering they have all of their legs
still it's okay at this point they're like pugs they got
breathing problems oh yeah they're okay that's just how you
keep them alive it's a hips they hit us no no no please no
please oh well oh my hey are you still alive dude i heard
him begging for his life bro no that was ad wasn't ad no one
telling me not to kill him they were just going no please no
it's kind of based when you think about it like it took sure
for five hours to become a prime raptor and all he did was
kill a hipsy listen it didn't it didn't it didn't say why i
shouldn't kill it it just said no you
kid man well you have to think about it i'm like a cat
they're they're agony and they're agony and like oh t-rexes
um oh there's a really big one i'm getting one more bite i'm
gonna eat this i mean they could be chill wait no no no
stripping play it up be like look at we killed these two
guys yeah yeah let me eat him yo what up guys you hungry
yeah come eat we killed these two guys Do you think that's
cool?
We got full tummies, man.
They're not saying shit.
They don't care about us.
Wait, they're in...
What?
Did they DC?
Why are they just walking forward?
So how do I get past this really big wall?
They 100% crash.
Wait, can we kill them?
No, don't kill them when they crash.
yeah i just heard somebody say please don't kill me i need
water wait oh it's that little tread over there wait should
i i'm gonna go kill him don't kill the little babies you are
such a shit fucking raptor man it's like a pickle of food
that doesn't even do anything but it's not about the food
it's about killing them yeah where is he where's the way the
dinosaur it's just a little guy i'm i'm scared of finding
out you guys have to be careful for where these rexes like
respawn yeah it's like they're gonna spawn like who puked on
the ground here the food rotted right before i ate it and
i'm sick oh no i got stuck in a tree if you find the salt
rock you can lick it and oh the rexes despawn up there right
there oh back where they were you hear them talking they're
loading they said oh my god justin crashed holy I see a
little guy who's behind them.
They just said there's raptors right there.
You might have to scare them off real quick.
I hear them talking.
I don't hear them talking.
Hey, guys.
They said there's two of y'all.
You can't die to raptors.
They ain't even prime.
Oh, damn.
Damn.
You see them?
Damn, that's fun.
Medium-sized dude.
How can I hear him?
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
Hey, can you guys hear me?
My mo- no, I'm still in my mumble.
Yeah, my mumble.
Hello?
What's the issue, man?
Yeah, we- we're just hanging out!
Bro!
What the hell's wrong with you?
what the fuck we're just hanging yeah we just hang out we
can't hang out anymore who got hit ben brain does i think oh
those are literally friends talking to each other saying
protect us scare them away that's dude that's against the
rules they're cheating yeah they just walked up and said yo
this is my friend right here don't kill him it's a pt hey
what's up how can hear this dude he's just constantly
talking in my ear we can't hear them oh there's a flying guy
i can hear one of them just talking in my ear this whole
time just restart your mumble or like disconnect and
reconnect wait should we all do that i did that real quick
did you hear them now dude are those guys fucking stupid we
could have killed those fucking t-rexes like ages ago well
i'm restarting my mumble yeah too
now yeah the dude's just talking he was asking to protect
the t-rexes that dc then they're just teaming up i'm killing
myself oh i hear them now what the fuck looks like wait ben
we're just gonna kill you they can't catch you know about
that you talking to him
surely i spawn closer wait what do we do to you guys we're
just chilling Yeah
Whoa, he hit me Of course he hit you.
Yeah, I read though his range was so far
See they're not even talking to us.
Oh, yeah, dude How did I not jump on him wait he was doing
like the bucking animation dude, let's just get the freak
out of here Yeah, I think he doesn't he doesn't fuck with us
us oh i shot in the water that's fine yeah the fuck wait we
have to cross the road bro thinks he's like tough when we're
not even trying to like attack him yeah we were just
chilling maybe his mumbles he broke his leg they're gonna
find out they're gonna find out hey he broke his leg yeah
wait never mind they did it they said they did it's a pt bro
i'm reconnecting hey there What's up, man?
They don't want to hear me.
They don't want to talk to us.
We're not cool enough.
Is it just a bunch of people freaking mixing together?
Oh, hey!
There's like in Discord to each other thinking he's talking
to just each other, but he's talking to mumble.
How's he hanging up there?
I think I spawned kind of closer.
They don't want to talk to us.
We're not cool enough.
find out you I did all right bro operation find me me do we
god do it dude that's not happening they don't know no no
how are we supposed to find them where are we gonna should
we do the location the operation right now I'm coming I'm
coming the operation right now is to go to north jungle and
north plain so we can get freaking prime on rain and
everyone that hasn't gotten their zones yet it's me ben
annie and rain i'm i'm stuck at like 54 on every people and
he has them i'm not really growing a little damaged and
hungry now because i was sick yeah we'll find food along the
way don't worry we'll find food
what was that guy that was trying to hurt us it's a maya
they're like one of my favorite dinos to play dude it's so
sick wait why are they your favorite why is it favorite yeah
because they you switch between four legs and two legs and
then when you're in two legs you're yeah you run like
insanely quick and then you can shoulder tackle dynos and
knock them over and then just stamp on them oh that's one
that killed you that's why he was able to catch up to you
guys yeah yeah i was gonna say they're so quick dude but
they can't turn very well i need to recharge my stamina i
think i see a dead dinosaur right there it was a corpse here
hey guys ben you said you're i mean rains you said you're
hungry right yeah all right well he eat i was running make
me more hurt it looks like it does no only if you're
bleeding are you bleeding no okay then you're fine i need a
recharge stamina she's just straight east of us yeah she's
by delta
pretty epic good ass food dude 160 growth rate
well yeah we're gonna go we're gonna go through north jungle
hit them johns
chillin go to north plains
there's a bunch of people near us from the then where what
are you doing all the way over there why don't you rest near
us wants to recharge his full stamina fully if you come rest
on me you're in inside the pg what does that mean i like how
we've been talking about this oh wait it's for prime prime
and you just you literally five five hours five hours no it
clicked in my head it clicked the neurons are just not
firing at all it's like what's that i just i remember the
moment how do i use the map oh thanks for teaching me the
map ben put in the coordinates for me
resting in the pz what's
your growth at rain uh 65.
have you been doing your mutations i did one the bleeding
damage you should have the second mutation by now i don't so
the acid is not old enough we should you should have your
starting one one more right i don't think you i think you
didn't do it in time and now you just have oh minus one
mutation i'm growing like really slow I'm at 80% of the
growth.
You're, oh, increased growth.
You're 80?
It increased 70.
Oh, 80%.
I'll just say.
Oh, it's going down though.
Let's get going, guys.
Okay.
We got a trek.
I think we're making good progress.
Oh no, we're making great progress now.
we got almost got about we almost got like four adults and
if we get enough pz's we shouldn't have like four primes and
then we can attack anything we where's on the stats where's
on the tab page when you when you clear a pz wait what
growth are you at now 85 matt 83 yeah you're about to you're
basically max weight would you say dokey we're in the tab
does it show like the pz stuff it doesn't I'm using the map.
I showed you six times.
No, I meant like when you hit it.
It doesn't.
Oh, so you would know because when you hit 75, you unlock
two mutations instead of one.
If you unlock one mutation, you didn't hit it.
If you unlock two, it means you hit it.
I see.
Also, I'm running out of stamina already.
Have you been spamming jump?
No.
Actually, I did it.
I don't know why I'm a stamina decrease fast.
You have to have been spamming jump because there's
literally zero chance.
I swear we just never made it back to full oh if she took
full damage it would have taken stamina if she did a job if
she went off a cliff yeah I think we took fall damage going
into the water running away from that guy and then we just
haven't I'm not fully charged oh wait so like if I'm not
fully up it goes down faster yeah oh I did not know that and
if your Sam is like at the tips of rate i see uh diet is the
only way yeah gotcha the more vitamins you have the more
pirates it feels like it tastes so loud to recharge stamina
all the way up yeah yeah the way the longer you sit the
faster it is and that's how it comes back if you if your
stamina is over half it regenerates on its own if you don't
sprint okay
we could probably just make bridges during the once you get
to half we could probably just not sprint and just move
normal job all right oh my gosh i'm guys see i'm learning
i'm learning guys guys don't worry now i figured it out guys
it's so good we just want to hit prime we've been trying to
get prime but it's taking a while we died so many times this
is my first time guys the way you become a giga giga raptor
of hell is every time you entombed you get four new
mutations and the mutations you already have get increased
yep i don't know why he's barking he's already eaten he's
had his food i guess i'm about to grow up 72.
wait that's bad wait yeah going through the zone yeah isn't
that bad Yes.
We gotta get going.
I'm not, wait, I don't know if I'm halfway yet.
The toes.
Okay, wait, wait, I can, I think I can, I'm halfway.
I'm halfway.
I'm ready.
Let's just walk.
We don't have to sprint.
I'm ready.
Why are we trying to get to?
Am I going to Northern Jungle?
Yeah.
All right.
There's a guy singing.
I'm really scared.
because i'm going through water say hi to him i'm pretty
sure he's friendly what if it's a crocodile singing dude
that's yeah he's throwing you like an angler fish he's
trying to lure you in that was so fun i like that you see
that oh watch out oh shit whoa we got a biting time hey stop
that i got a biting ow that's rude he might break his leg
It's two of them.
Well, he reigns on his own, dude.
I got on one for a bit.
Oh my god.
Oh god, I'm going to die after the fall damage, aren't I?
Oh, I'm scared.
What?
What got you?
Hey, Ben, I fucking went up.
Nice.
Get this guy.
No, no, no.
What are you doing?
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking him up.
why are they too cute wait someone said oh i died yeah
they're biting you off of each other guys you got to be
careful when they're together because they can bite you yeah
you can so you can dodge and i'm dodging you you can press
let a s a dodging to like change sides on a dino i was up oh
i didn't know i would get one shot i'm out of sam i gotta uh
guys yeah i'm sorry and you have anybody that's yeah me and
ben are both on that guy for like 30 seconds straight i'm
pretty sure someone jumped on me and then it like fucked me
up well i know it wasn't me because i jumped on stripping he
beat my ass dude yeah yo wait wait annie's leading one to
you guys uh so these guys have crazy bleed resist by the way
we probably aren't gonna bleed him you have to left click
damage doki are you at full health no i'm not bleeding
wait the bleed isn't health dokey wait no but i see red yeah
if you don't if you keep running around you don't sit to get
rid of the bleed then uh i need to sit all right i sit wait
one of one of them just threw up because the other one bit
him he's fucking hurt no i'm i can't chase i'm out of
stamina i'm at like literally one shot yeah we're rough i
mean we did we scared them off yeah it's all right we did
that guy yeah we lost rain fucked up yeah we lost rain
though so i said like wsd i can like hop around and dodge
them if the other yeah you can like hop on the back of them
and swap sides and stuff so they can't bite you off i tried
to jump on one twice and i just got like locked in place
yeah i don't know it was this is like this weird bug right
now where if they just mash left click and you pounce them
it cancels your animation and you just get stuck oh so like
that happened to me and it happened to uh two or four as
well I'm just scared of jumping on because I might have been
because the terrain was weird it's hard to say well Doki you
just have to jump on a spot where one of the raptors isn't
attached not on top of them I just jumped on them and it it
led me on this trip and I got scared after that wait they're
both throwing up well so they probably were biting each
other because when Oh shit, they both threw up two times.
Annie and Ben were switching spots.
I'm making them bite.
It means that they're like diet is fucked up and their
hunger and thirst is fucked up, yeah.
Oh, is that good for us?
Oh, well, my Sam is back.
I'm down to go on them.
It means they heal much slower.
Oh.
Because they lost all their food.
I think I'm like one hit away and I die though.
Yeah, I don't think we should go again.
This is stupid.
We just, we chill if they come back and try to fuck with us,
we can like.
I haven't seen them sit yet though.
which means they're just bleeding out.
Yeah, I got my healing up.
I'm about to grow as well.
I was fucking both of them up.
Oh yeah, you were.
I hopped on top of the back and I think they bit each other
because I hopped above them.
Yeah, they were biting each other a lot.
That's how they killed her.
They're leaving.
They went down the hill.
It might be going down to heal up.
I'm still pretty wounded.
Yeah, I just want to keep eyes on them.
A lot of pain.
If I can eat one of them, I can heal up.
Dude, I was looking at the fucking T-Rexes and those guys
just randomly were in front of me.
Yeah, they're down by the dock right now.
They're sick.
They're eating rain to heal.
They're healing by a rock.
I see.
Well, they nerfed that.
You can't heal that much from that anymore.
Wait, what?
The rock heals?
We could scare them a little bit.
Not commit, but scare them.
They're stopped.
They're finally sick.
They stopped their bleed right now.
I mean, it takes a while to start.
Wait, wait.
switching the timing not if we going first down i'm just
like literally one shot we it is risky because we are kind
of on the verge of growing up right there i see him yeah and
the other one's under that rock to the left i'm 0.3 from
growing up yeah yeah i mean this fight is so winnable if
we're just adults i think we just let them go we can't just
keep we can't just keep living scrap life with one yeah
we're close we just gotta be patient is the server restart
is gonna fuck everyone's pz's awesome nice wait really
doesn't matter yeah wait so we got nothing to lose then i'm
a 70 bro are you kidding me wait i got prime yeah wait you
got prime you got prime so if you can click the second one
and it says like yeah i think i think i am fine nice oh my
god restart 70 percent hey mr pal i put a gun in my mouth
dog maybe it might be fine but i've noticed whenever i dc or
server resarts it fucks it up a lot but you could be fine
i'm just gonna i just have to chance it if it doesn't if i
don't get it maybe i just in tune yeah in tune at 100 and
then go again yeah what if i save logout right now maybe it
will save it uh i think logging out also
Yeah, we should safe log.
I've had it work after server restart, but it's funky.
Yeah, I am safe logging out.
Wait, at least someone got prime.
At least Ben got prime.
That's big.
Yeah, I think Doki should too, if it happens before the
server resets.
Oh, I'm not safe log out.
Just in case.
I'm at 70.
Wait, is it 70% when?
75 is when you need.
When you find out.
Oh, I'm 70.4.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, at least so.
Yeah, I'm gonna safe log out and hope it saves my prime.
Oh, do I save?
Should I save too?
Yeah, press H to sit and then hold H and it should stay
until safe log out.
If I was able to get on one of their backs, one of those
guys probably dies.
Oh, I was one minute till safe.
They were so close.
Yeah.
No, I 100% one of them dies if I am able to get on one, but
I had two jumps where I just like...
Yeah, you were just sat there and they were biting you.
jumped and went off the cliff and then and i was down there
on one and being bent around one guy for like 30 seconds i i
was on one of their sides for a second and then i started
getting bit from the other side and then i jumped yeah i was
on that same one with you and i jumped off oh my eye but i
just stood on it i don't think i'd get one shot well if you
needed to go to the washroom or get some snacks or something
the server restart usually takes like 15 20 minutes does
actually yeah I don't what I think like 10 or 15 something
like that it takes a little bit I'll go make a sandwich yeah
make a what kind of sandwich I'm probably doing it peanut
butter and honey I think yummy yummy gigafree so seven
minutes after the hour normally oh yay I'm safely locked
locked out so you just wait until the server resets you soon
Yeah.
Miu has already collectively had more deaths than the entire
group combined at the time.
Yeah.
She's so mean and cruel to me.
Be kind.
Wait, she's actually really close to us.
I know.
I ran all the way and all he does is bully me.
I don't know.
You haven't given us any updates.
She has.
I have the entire time.
You are so mean and cruel.
come back like directly south of us but you always come back
i do so what does that say about you i'm cool and way cooler
than that guy that's true well except we get a quick cg very
important detail i'm gonna can't hear you wait do you want
me to say it no please don't be mean to me like ben i
finally got my royal titan scroll being mean it's something
you told me to never reveal yes oh be quiet some juice
i'm gonna what do you do with these points i'm gonna feed my
dog i'll be right there you have 25k points you can have a
storage slot oh i see i see yes how many points you go that
was like hey you want to eat me that's what he was doing how
much do i have yeah oh let's see i got 7500 which is not bad
when i start today so you must have way more well the you
get like a daily point thing that you can redeem and like it
gets higher and higher if you do it subsequently but i think
i have 17k and one storage slot i have a a prime Sarah in
storage oh you do yeah damn Sarah player man uh I just did
it once I have 24k points right now so I could get another
storage spot in one capable I've always hated Sarah dude
why do you hate him like playing him or against them both I
just hate that they gave them bleed resist doesn't make any
sense they basically because they they introduced them at a
time when it was like carnos raptors and saras and then
saras were just stronger than carnos but half the grow time
and immune to raptors and it was like they were just fucking
way too op and then they could just eat they could just eat
anything to heal to fall they also get damage resistance
with their near dead bodies yeah the huffing shit it's like
a crazy dude plus the the making you vomit oh dude slow
though.
Overloaded as fuck.
How long until the server reset's done?
Usually seven minutes after the hour, so like in six
minutes.
Oh, so long.
The last thing I did before I logged out on my server was I
had a body I was camping and like a giant arrow came to try
to eat from it and I just fucking devoured him from a bush.
Holy shit.
Do you ever log back in to find out?
What do you mean?
devour him?
No, I killed him.
He was dead.
Wait, I thought you can talk while you're dead, dead.
What?
Wasn't that Segasaurus talking to us when he, like, fucking
got a heart attack?
No, the other one that was alive was talking to us.
Oh, I thought it was like...
Wait, you thought the corpse was chatted to us while we were
eating it?
God, bro.
I thought it was a different guy talking.
Doki, how stupid are you right now?
low-key I'm sober that's just who I am this is just you
that's just me I thought it was the dead guy talking because
he was it seemed like he was no way you see two stagos walk
up to us and one of them goes yo I'm about to store do you
want to eat my body I bet and the other one that is alive
next to us is like yo if i log on to my raptor i literally
and the whole time you think the other stago is just
listening to us just chilling with the dead one is speaking
to us that's what's going on through your brain wait the
crazy shit was that you turned to the other one and you were
like how does it feel to have your friend being ean and he
was like how would you like to join him but it was the same
voice as what you must have thought the other thing was it
seemed like they He changed his voice pitch and it sounded
like a different voice.
You think he just randomly changed his voice pitch?
It was a different guy.
I gotta make a sounder.
This is too much.
He sounded different.
I swear.
I swear he sounded different.
I swear to God.
You're zooted on some shit right now.
I'm not.
I don't do drugs at all.
You 100% do drugs.
I've never done any drugs.
You gotta be high on Molly.
No.
I've never done I've only drank alcohol and I'm sober I'm
sober right now you have to be drunk as fuck you must be
drunk as fuck mix I just thought I thought it was two
different guys talking it was two different guys talking I
thought it was just a feature where if you get a heart
attack so that's like a spectator thing we wasn't a heart
attack they stored in the meantime you can look at super
spanish cosplay wait super cosplay as a wait someone someone
understood the reference is it w fax huh that's up to you
and did he tweet at the cosplay out how about how about you
keep that one to yourself annie you don't like that phrase
no
I'm trying my best guys why did Ben link me the cosplay did
he like look at the Annie did he I didn't get it it's in the
discord oh it's in the this oh I thought you'd personally
okay wait but the drifter and silver cosplay yeah wait this
is peak I like how it's just coordinates it's just all
coordinates All coordinates from people that can't just use
the website by themselves.
There was an attempt.
Oh, no, he definitely does have the fake boobs thing.
Yeah.
You're...
Estrogen can save her.
For those who want to see Super in the cosplay, I'll send
you the link, guys.
Why is the account Super TF Yowie?
I don't.
no i'm i i'm pretty sure that's just self-explanatory it's
all cosplays that he's done uh if you guys are still playing
later i might join i gotta go call a friend all right all
right no problem but if i don't see you thank you for the
games anytime yeah ggs
guys am i that i'm not that stupid right they sounded
different right guys they sound guys it's not just me right
they sounded different right throughout the entire day yeah
wait annie did ask those wfaps got the link then immediately
left suspicious i have to call a friend quotations right
after he's she saw the the super cosplay yeah it's pretty
hmm that's pretty suspicious I
mean she has the whole account to look through now it's
literally like a little storage of all his
cosplays if I want to learn tank and rivals who should I
play I like the brawlers I like like rogue and shit Thor's
good rogue's good that's really good right now cap's meta
cap's boring though yeah that's boring but he is meta boring
i see coming in every game emma's always strong yeah oh it's
back up yay let's get just logged in and said nothing fucker
i was responding to his initial question
well nobody's in it I'm in Well, first person in it Waiting
for my pack
Solid Solid Snake, thank you The Super Chat, thank you,
thank you They love you for who you are, Jokey Don't worry
about it Yeah, it's like Smart You love me Because I'm smart
In the same bush, too Solid, they use The Chat, they, thank
you Oh, they use the Super Chat Thank you, thank you It's
okay, we still love you You're a stupid Comey ocean Like,
yeah, the other way potentially still around I see you I'm
back hello everybody oh wait you guys where things are not
grouped anymore yeah rain you coming back he's pooping hey
guys I'm right behind you put me in the group sure pack
leader yeah he's hiding in a bush he's right over here just
bushing it out all right i'm gonna go back and lay down
because i'm in pain yeah we're fucked up we're down to four
i have so much fps while everyone isn't loaded in i know
dude that's true all right we're also chilling in the bush
um i'm pretty close but i'm laying down because my stamina
is poo-poo-poo yeah we're laying closer wait how close can i
grab you she's she's like right around the rock from us so
please She's real close.
She's gonna grab me.
Oh, nice.
I'd say heal up.
Yeah, I was gonna say, don't you need a heal?
Well, where's Adi?
So, funny thing about that, Ben linked Super's cosplay or
talked about it, and she was like, is it W Fabs?
And then he linked it to everyone.
And then she said, I'm gonna be right back.
Yeah, I'm gonna make a call real quick, quote unquote.
take that information with what you will and and she was
like you guys will be back we guys will still be playing
right when I'm come back and we're like maybe so she is
coming back there's so I swear I've seen so many T rexes
today but it's supposed to be like a limited role are you
sure for this server huh for this server this limited yeah
assume most servers Yeah, I feel like, yeah, we saw, like, a
ton.
Dinosukas and T-Rex are limited because if there is too
many, then it'd just be like...
It'd be, like, turbo broken.
Everyone said, wait, I just saw Dinosukas.
This is the lake we don't drink out, by the way.
Wait, why?
Yeah, I just saw a Dinosukas over there.
This is alligator hell.
Oh.
But there's barely any alligators, though.
Hey, you can take a drink out of water.
You can test it.
they spawn so they normally just stay in this lake oh yeah i
was gonna say we're that makes sense i think we can drink
from like a little like enclosed area though you can
literally see one talking to the rex right now they're like
best friends i mean there's a hole in that enclosed area
yeah i don't feel like risking it at this point we should be
safe long does it take to heal i got the perk to heal faster
and it's still taking a long ass time i got the one where i
eat i heal but i wish i'd know how i wish i'd know my hp
it's just the amount of red on your screen yeah i know but
still it's still i still see the splatters around me tossing
this a moment if it's the super one just not a month time to
enjoy it bro
Are you going to pick up pick her up now?
No, we are.
Please come save me.
Can you move from where you are?
I don't think so.
We'll just wait over here on this cliff.
Doki come come join us.
Hey guys, I'll go be cliffside raptors with all of you.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm not blending into the bush at all.
I don't see anybody at all No, they got Oh, they found me Oh
no They found me Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, there's a guy over here And he Maybe he said he means me
no harm And he called me a little guy So I think we're
friends Alright, so run around the rock Keep the rock on
your right There's a road I'm on my road I mean you no harm
Little guy Me before I fucking kill someone Yeah, that
sounds like a bait right there.
Don't trust him me before I fucking rip you off you rip you
and off She wants you to get closer.
Do you know what do you know what it was?
You look like us It looked kind of like us But it was like
Yeah, I think you would know He's a homie.
I think He's gonna get you killed Ben.
She's gonna get you killed No, he's gone.
He left.
I see him.
That looks nothing like us.
I tried my best.
Was he a big guy?
Um, does he walk onto your legs?
Yeah, but that's like everything.
Is he greenish?
Yo, they're back.
They're back.
Shuffle.
They're coming up the hill.
Oh, shit.
Get in the trees.
I think I'm finally going up around.
All right.
hide in the bush rip it there's there's activities happening
i'm scared oh i see the road don't go on the road imagine mu
dies to them just as she oh no they look they're hunting us
bro big time do they see us they woke up they woke up and
instantly just sprint out the hill to exactly where we were
sitting oh my god now they're in the trees looking for us
buddy just stay mobile They're slow and they turn bad and
they can't really fight in the trees.
And you saw me.
I ran away.
I heard footsteps get close to me and I dips it.
I have one on me.
Oh, they're on me?
No!
Why me?
Just run.
Oh my god, I got trapped in the rock.
Come to me, come to me, Doki.
No, I'm going down the rock.
I'm going down the rocks.
Okay, don't go too far.
Don't fall and die.
i won't
why are they chasing me i'm still so hurt dude this is oh it
takes a while to heal i just actually have to sit down again
i'm trying to find you guys i'm in the i'm gonna tree push
right now are they still following me i don't know i don't
hear them those freaks they hunger bro all right dokey i'm
gonna stay between you and the others so that you can see my
name yeah i don't know when to come back to you as he they
gave up chasing me because i ran down the hill did ben did
you not find me uh no there was a giant thing running down
the road he told me to hide so i'm in a bush yeah just let's
stay safe we don't want these things that are Once we're all
adults, we can fuck with them.
We're almost there, to be fair.
Yeah, they didn't want to take the fall damage.
You're scared.
If you look at the map, the dot that you linked, we are in
the forest that, like, is northwest past the rock of you.
The forest that goes, like, west to east.
Near site F11.
When do I come back, guys?
I mean, you can come by now.
All right.
Totally fine.
Yeah, you can come back whenever you want.
You're faster than them.
You can jump.
You're quicker in the trees.
You turn better.
If you just run, they can't do anything.
Yeah, they're pretty slow chuds.
That's good to know.
I'm slowly heading back the mountain.
I hope I don't see no dinosaur up this mountain.
I'm going to meet you.
I'm almost there.
Oh, I hear that.
that's a little scary they're screaming hello yo this way
now we can see stripping gets prime probably not right
because of the restart well there's a chance yeah there's a
chance dokey we see if dokey gets it too oh that's true
that's true betty gets it i should she's just i was next to
him unless unless i restart talk to you 73 almost at 74 it's
73.896 i'm a 73.5 we're about the same once everyone's
adults we can start fucking people up yeah that's what we've
been waiting for having two primes is good enough yeah this
health region i believe in us this is what we've been
working on that's why i got to eat food to get health
because even though it's low it's still
You know what, that's what the, that's what the, the, the
six hours of, of, of, I was four guys.
A lot of it was learning experience.
A lot of it was me dying, chirping.
Wait, Mr. Kyle, what did you tell me?
Why is there this creepy music going on?
Because you're about to die.
It means something's looking directly at you.
I feel like you're lying.
No, no, no, no.
He's right.
haven't something's been watching me it's like yeah you're
getting stalked right now oh man do you follow that road
that you saw with the rock on your right and then look
forward across like the plane there is another forest and
that's where we are rock on your right okay it's very misty
i need water you should probably go to highland lake down
south yeah it's for me can you just coast your course i need
some water water soon too also i'm kind of schizoed out now
wait did you got bit no but i heard scary music scary music
we could just go straight east as well chufour and just
drink from the river like on the rocks crocodiles monkey you
go nah because the it's like seven different waterfalls this
river and the crocodiles have to go off land for each
segment so they don't use it that's why they're stuck in the
lake i'm down for either
we're just chilling we're just chilling in the bush it's
with the homies 74.5 dude oh i'm 74.4 wait you're faster
yeah maybe what's your growth rate i'm at 49.79 it just
keeps going down oh i'm 120 that's what the fuck he got his
nutrients i got his nutrients like on my good diet i thought
i was eating good but i'm eating good what we were eating
the same meal you just don't you don't know how to eat good
you know what you weren't eating organs i bet you just oh
yeah i'm not freaking adding an emote of super tf jiggling
his fake tits wait is it ready is it already on uh seven tv
yeah does someone already make it wait how many have it
added you can see that oh my 67 channels already flash me
trips and kills every moon viewer right super added added on
his own channel of course he did how is mu still not found
us i'm trying my best
i'm almost there okay you've been saying that for seven
years I'm trying Wait did you get already have prime
stripping you should have it soon
74.7 oh yeah, that's your sandwich as good as fuck I made
two.
I'm on my second one.
Well, you're 74.7.
Oh I'm 74.89.
Oh, oh, I'm in oh I didn't I didn't get prime That's live.
I get prime.
Wait, you might still got it.
You don't know.
Wait, you're not sure.
You have to do your third perk.
Oh, I'm the third?
Oh, okay.
What should I get?
What you got already?
I got the hunger one and the and the fall damage.
Reduce incoming damage when fighting larger species.
Oh, which one is that?
Hypoargazia.
Jesus Christ, that's a long word.
worry about it so i think mu said i'm lost no i didn't i
jumped off the i didn't only a little bit wait the what what
was it called oh reduce income damage by fighting larger
species i was running yeah okay uh all right we have a
fourth one yeah you go prime i'm prime see even i can get
prime Look, God, okay, what should I get for the fourth one,
then strip in?
Whatever you want.
Follow your heart.
Oh, my heart?
Okay, what about stripping?
You get prime?
I don't know you.
I'm getting hungry and thirsty.
So you, can you push?
Yeah, haven't we been waiting for Mew for the past 10
minutes?
Wait, I should get the eating one, right?
Be kind.
Mew coordinates, please.
I posted them.
do realize we are stopping ourselves from going and getting
water to wait for you and you have been trying to go west
for seven hours let's just go get her can you please help me
these are really hard to understand and then i saw someone
and they scared you literally have an active map where you
can see where you are and you can decide whether you're
going north east west or south
We're primed now.
We're primed the fuck out.
We're primed.
Yeah, but look at the corner.
We're so primed.
And then ran back to the same corner.
She was not before.
Hater.
Okay.
Rock on your right.
Go to the right.
Rock on my left.
One ducky.
Okay.
I'm done.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's because I need to go back.
We're primed.
I need to go back to negative 227.
You know it's bad when fucking Ben was like, I give up.
Guys.
there's four primers we go full prime raptors look i'm
getting really really close to you we're at four in front
wait you said that like 10 minutes ago we're just standing
in the middle of the open right now could you look to your
left if the rock all right can you hear this mu yeah no can
you hear this can you just go into the open clearing mu like
where the fuck are even are you what is by this rock the way
that i'm pointing she's over there so why doesn't she just
go into the open clearing like the rest god only knows i i
what open clearing are you sure are you sure she's close to
us what if yes i'm a hundred percent she's right she's
literally right in front of us and then how come we don't
see you guys here surely you hear this unless she'd run the
opposite direction.
Why is my chat saying Ben can alt, Ben press alt?
I'm not gonna alt.
I know what is, whoa, you alt on me, but not her?
Yes, because you should know better.
Wait, is she on the right server?
I know, right?
That would be way crazy.
I am on the right server.
Okay, you ran somehow, okay.
Wait, give us cores again.
Go directly west.
She did, go directly west an open field to the west does she
know about the compass at the top of her screen i taught her
every time you've tried to teach her something in vintage
stories there's someone on that mountain rain taught me but
he didn't do it right i don't know what to do hi it's him i
broke my ankle oh my god look how tiny she is i'm abandoning
i'm abandoning me i need to get water yeah i need You know,
they're coming here.
Just follow us.
Okay.
You did get the rounds to rock.
Ah.
You guys are the same color as the dirt.
Oh, Pac is here, guys.
We did it.
I missed Rain, dude.
He died valiantly.
That guy's a loser.
We don't get him.
I was on the quitter.
Annie was about to be...
If I hit prime, Annie would hit prime.
Yeah.
Annie is um yeah yeah yeah yeah we know yeah taking a while
yeah this way it feels like it's just going to take us to
the reservoir careful don't sprint okay i have the salmon of
fall damage yeah when i'm queuing what is the thing that has
like two circles on the sides of like two lemons uh that's a
virtual zone
I'm not gooning shut up sounds like something someone that
was gooning would say wait we're going the wrong way oh well
how do I growl I mean we're going this way is toward a river
yeah wait what the fuck is this thing oh it's a little baby
triceratops oh we're not you're a baby triceratops I'm chill
guys What's up guys we're chill We're chill We're not chill
You motherfuckers just left bones You don't eat the bones
They're bad What was that little baby triceratops?
You should have fed the baby man Me you're still hungry Yeah
I'm stuck What the fuck do you mean?
That's kind of sorry If we don't make it Wait wait Wait a
minute me through too many hells in vintage story it's
transcended into the aisle yeah but you yeah but you still
you still took care of her in in the game no i didn't oh he
killed me and he beat me but you still keep back that baby
triceratops is a rabbit yeah i have a problem it was so
thank you we chill we chill we're not chill oh up to it yes
yeah yeah we said we were like we're not chill though we're
hungry i didn't say anything to him i just ate his ass i
just told him we're not chill there's the bridge right here
so we should be watching careful for heroes can't believe
i'm prime i never knew how that felt i need some stamina man
i did it slashing me wallows in the mud i need some water
Wait, I wanna roll around.
What's the advantages of wallowing in the mud?
Bloody.
And if you're bleeding, you can like get rid of the- Oh,
like patches.
You need our crocodile bait?
Come here.
Wait, what?
I like how you're like, we gotta take care of our children
and you say, hey, crocodile bait, chop, chop.
I did my duty.
I'm scared.
But I just covered myself in some yummy mud.
I think I'll be okay.
Yeah, so that means the crocodile can't find you.
I drink out of the yummy water.
Water time.
There are any crocodiles here.
I'm really friendly.
Well, maybe there is going to be now.
Wait, I found I found a really... Wait, look at this spot's
safe as fuck, isn't it?
Why?
What do you mean why?
Why is...
No, I can't see it, so I can't...
Because the crocodile can't get you through the...
Oh!
Oh,
there's no room for little old me.
Oh, don't worry.
Here you go.
You could take my spot right there.
Oh, thank you.
No problem.
I've never been in the presence of a pram before, so.
You'll get there.
That's your first time playing a fucking game.
You'll get there in two to three hours.
There's someone asking you for friendly.
Are you friendly?
Someone's asking for friendly?
Wait, we're not friendly.
What kind of dinosaur are you?
I'm just a baby.
Wait, they're just a baby?
Can you come under the bridge?
No, I'm a grass eater.
I think you're not very...
You're not very...
Lunch, lunch, lunch.
Yeah, that doesn't sound too convincing.
Or is he?
Are they in this bush?
Doesn't sound too convincing.
I don't know.
Don't you see me eating this grass?
Yum, yum, yum.
Sounds like I'm in one of these bushes.
I think he crossed the bridge.
I think he could see us searching for him.
I'm pretty sure they're in one of these bushes close to us.
Oh, you sound like he was legit right next to me.
I found him.
No, please.
This is the first time.
He said, no, please.
Oh, what kind of dino is he?
I don't know.
What is this?
Is this a harrow?
Yeah, I don't feel bad.
It looks like a rat.
All right.
Yum, yum time.
Let the kid eat, man.
Let the kid eat.
We go.
We think big mouthfuls.
Oh, my God, it's gone.
Where did it go?
Oh, oh, I suddenly need to heal up.
I'm using my perk.
Thank you.
I was the crocodile bait, so.
i think i should just and i baited that guy into staying i
think i think i think you baited him into hiding he just let
me walk up and just eat him i'm gonna move and try and run
he's begging for his life all right where's your next i
don't know just my tail we across this bridge head to
see if anyone's over there yeah let's go go we gotta try and
get me you prime we need more food yeah yeah we i want to
take down where we were on the road before well we could
turn around and grab rain we were before before we went to
the lake there's a bunch of t-rexes here and some other
people oh the delta right yeah you're a delta no no wherever
we were before we went to the areas like between the two
hills two mountains like a long road with the big pilot the
highland yeah it was a big rock yeah before highland lake
there's t-rexes roaring at me are you talking about the
sanctuary yeah i think so oh your little baby a t-rex won't
kill you you're barely like sustenance for them you should
bite its ankles i should we got a long way to go and they
can't run away from you.
Pretty sure this is the wrong way to...
Oh.
Wait, wait.
He's going straight south.
He's at the sanctuary.
We have to go west.
Where are we supposed to go?
All right, following, stripping.
No, there's that.
No, we need to get this one.
Everyone's going a different direction, guys.
Should I trust him?
I don't think you guys are going there right now.
Let's see.
Following stripping.
Back to where we were, but...
That's where he is, man.
Like, when we were fighting those guys.
no you're wrong where we were fighting the guys is north but
somebody has to be right it's me no it's me smirks
i think we're going the wrong direction the leader if only
gullibles was here in his basement didn't get fucking
flooded maybe i'll come back maybe i'll fix the basement by
then yeah just fix an entire basement that's flooded is that
easy he said he was drinking it flooded and he had a
different kind of basement get flooded yeah i mean he's
drinking it with his roommate so eventually yeah yeah it's
like teamwork like 30 minutes more just hear someone cry out
to our left i'm at the lake that's me you're just making
noises oh it wasn't i did that i'm at highland lake whoops
all right we're on the way well you caught some air there
yeah actually jumped whoopsie kind of starving already we'll
look for some food while we're on the way there's probably
food at highland lake we're gonna eat food soon guys when i
was trying to get those over here at the sanctuary is that a
dead body i think it looked like one looks like it i'm
hungry careful for a tree that's a trunk oh it's a tree it's
a tree i don't think you can eat it no you can't
good peace anything will be fine guys can i do more than
just like one growl except for like other growls one two
three and four are all different one is like uh normal cool
two is friendly three is mad and four is like what's four uh
four is like surrendering oh i'm so surrendering oh no can
they tell which ground doing no oh can i tell the one three
because three like hiss and do calls and shit oh i see and
then one is like the Jurassic Park slash me rests up a bit
yeah yeah dude my stamina is cooked my stamina is depleted
fully i mean shit at the lake well there should be a shit
ton at the sanctuary yeah better run back to the sanctuary
time to sleep and that stamina back up oh my god it's a dino
puddle yo what times will come tomorrow I want to watch like
2 30 oh I'm sorry yeah you're talking about soccer versus 2
30 4 CST or something yeah it's 2 30 p.m.
PST
or I'm gonna use the bathroom while we're all regaining
stamina, I'll be right back.
Doki said she's going to the bathroom?
Yep.
All right, guys, we should leave.
I think I'm meeting a raptor.
Oh, well, you're not getting prime.
It's our way to tell that those raptors kind of decompose
and it's dark.
Are you in trouble?
You press tab and you have like, what's it called?
Shivers or something.
You'll have a cannibal debuff no i don't nice and you're
good because i really need food well we have to wait for
dogi to get back from the washroom or we leave and just tell
her to catch up that's not very kind of you you know what's
not very kind someone who's been told the same directions
they need to go i tried my best i'm going a circle i tried
my best i don't believe you that you tried your best i did
mr cow i wouldn't lie to you you lied to me a lot in vintage
story i mean that's a different story a different vintage
story uh that's a fucking new papa bro i don't get it
okay so there's no food in this game i'm leaving doggies you
say i can do them
i need food bad bro i know that's why i'm leaving got to be
red i mean she's she can just catch up she just needs to go
straight south west well i'll go scout the t-rex's at the
sanctuary
where did everybody go hey welcome back what the first time
we should leave you what why is because he's mean but i'm
prime we have multiple raptors that are starving right now
look you just you're pissing too long man i'm starving over
here i'm sorry i'll do a bathroom break all right we'll come
ben you're a real one ben and i could always count on you
i'll put i'm putting you in my will that's how real you are
no honor i'm all right i think we can just go left here
right there's a gap oh
yeah we need to
food i missed those stegosaurus's why because they're your
your adoptive parents i'm well them too but also the ones
also the ones that killed themselves to feed us i wish they
would do it again you didn't even know which one you were
talking to well she thought no she did she just thought it
was the same one i just thought they had the exact same
voice they sounded so similar she thought it was the same
one and then for some reason just decided to change his
voice our pack we are taking us i just thought like they
both sounded the same should i jump off oh we did not jump
off the cliff no you would get gross wings and flies away
that's how you got your leg fracture in the first place i
don't even realize how you broke your legs but
oh we're sorry i was sorry um i hate but we eat one of us
well we're all prime only one of us only one of us is meal
size then not prime no i'm really prime right now you're a
little chicken nugget man you know what is there no negative
effects for us eating raptors now right no no now there's no
there's so many Yeah, I feel like, all right, well, we all
know what's going to happen.
We start starving, right?
There's two somewhat medium dinosaurs eating in the middle
of the sanctuary on the road.
I feel pretty prime right now, guys.
Well, our casual resides up a mountain.
So we are slightly on the way.
Oh, they're chasing me.
Yeah, believe it to us.
Maybe adolescent T-Rex is.
Well, there's four primers now, so it should be fine.
Yeah, I mean, if we see something, we can easily take it,
but...
I just need to make sure I don't actually jump on you guys.
They're running away from T-Rex's, like, going northeast
side of the sanctuary.
Wait, they're coming to us.
Yeah, down the road, northeast side of the sanctuary.
We can cut them off.
Where are they?
i don't see anybody oh my belly's red that's not good oh
there is some angry dinosaurs fighting yeah well we can eat
all the meat after oh they're fighting right now three of
them are fighting some big uh wait are they third parties
i'm my stomach's gonna be red soon it's definitely like
hitting there in it's not the end of the world yeah you just
slowly yeah you're just yeah you're Oh, okay.
That's fine.
It's a problem when you're a juvie because then you can't
become prime.
Oh.
Because you become infertile.
Like goblins.
I see.
That makes sense.
Did he cannibalize?
No, he just didn't eat and he became infertile.
Okay, that's the message I don't like reading when we're
starving.
It says may happen, so maybe we'll be okay.
these are a lot of bushes guys i think we might have to make
a decision here no no no i feel so prime right now i think
um oh is this you that's me oh oh my god oh well you're not
dead they're not dead they're straight ahead but they're
eating some omnivore you know i just saw something in front
like i needed some comms there you know I have a bunch of
raptors.
You know you've been running into me for the past 10
minutes.
I have a bunch of raptors saying I'm fucking starving.
They have a ass to make us choice.
I'm not here red hunger as well.
I see something appear in front of me.
Bush, I'm jumping it to me.
Well, if you head straight that way, three guys are eating
an omnivore or a herbivore.
All right.
What were they?
Are they Sarahs?
I don't know.
Maybe.
I think they're Sarahs.
They're like sure four size.
I'm starving to death.
Were they like hoffing?
They had like the little arms.
Oh, they might.
Oh, the Kano's then.
Yeah.
I don't know the different dinosaurs.
They look like baby T-Rexes.
Yeah, they look like baby T-Rexes.
Yeah.
Oh, then we should just kill them.
Yeah, there's three of them.
Oh.
And they killed some herbivore.
I was eating them.
You think they'll have some left?
I'm clotting my blood and then I'm good to go.
Yeah.
It's all at last night when you guys start bleeding.
You sit.
till the bleeding stops.
Oh.
I hope we win the fight.
And there could be casualties.
There could not be.
I mean, I'm hungry enough that it's a fight to the death,
dude.
If you jump on someone's side, press W or A to get on their
back so other Raptors can get on the side.
Okay, W or A.
Okay.
Just like whatever direction is towards their spine.
And then don't jump on the back of another Raptor.
looks at them.
I don't know how long they're going to stay there.
They're running away from T-Rex's and...
I was trying to jump at the main guy, but then...
If you do pin a Raptor though, it's fine.
Just hit space and jump off straight away.
Okay.
Because if you hold it, you pin them down.
Yeah, but I jumped off straight away though.
I did.
I have like no stamina to try.
I'm also starting to do that.
I don't really think my blood stopped.
If it's a plus sign, it stops.
Why are you bleeding?
Because I'm hungry.
Oh, no, you can't stop that.
Yeah, you can't stop that.
You're not bleeding.
What?
Oh, man.
What's your age?
How much red is on your screen?
A lot, but not too, too much.
It's just like a lot.
A lot, but not too too.
Oh, wait.
Then we have to eat her then.
There's a T-Rex right in front of her.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If it's a lot.
There's a T-Rex in front of me in this bush.
Yeah, he's literally holding something.
Me too strong.
Dude, we're sorry about her.
hey we're sorry about her big dog oh she's not with us sorry
she's not with us she's new she's new i'm sorry i i see food
can i eat that southwest no please don't hurt me oh we got
that we got that baby raptor just jumped that t-rex and now
we're all gonna die for it we got that oh no i can't i i
won't be able to run anymore soon right here team come to me
i won't be able to like us the urban horror but yeah i'm
coming over to ben how much food do you have ben don't eat
all of us i i like them okay i'm gonna grab some now let's
hope the t-rex isn't pissed enough that he turns around no
she seems friendly she just said what to me oh i didn't hear
she seemed very kind i got one mouth for dude that's enough
to time here i need another one kill some let's check the
crush don't have anywhere you think up here let's go wait oh
what hey what the i'm still starving i'm still starving you
guys stripping okay wait why the frick would i kill
stripping we're hungry another bed of food right here is
that food yeah might eat yeah okay i'm good i'm good now i
filled it up a little bit who are in front of me what kind
no that's a al a sarah or no wait it looks like you're
eating me and i'm a little bit scared right now i'm coming
back oh oh i see them let's go then which way are you guys
jumping there's two it's it's just rain pass up i don't have
a lot of stamina so i'm just casually walking over you said
don't let them fit me oh there's a lot of them oh they run
in I got this one over here.
Yeah, I'm coming.
Oh, yummy.
Oh my god.
I crashed.
Oh, I got killed.
One of them visited me.
The other one just came and bashed into its friend and
killed us.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's how you have to make sure you get on the back.
Well, no, he like just ran his friend and took- Wait, one of
his friends crashed.
Oh, they're all dead.
I crashed.
No, no, they said- Did one of them die?
there's like i crashed i think shofo crashed and i think
they killed him oh they killed me i think well you know i
don't see you i mean what do you mean he crashed on top of
all of them no it might have my character might have just
been running off into the distance because i wasn't on the
back or anything oh that might yeah you might be okay i just
heard someone said i crashed i thought it was i thought they
crashed that's me saying i crashed oh no no i heard one of
the dinos say it the enemy dinos so i think someone else
also crashed what the worst time to crash mr kyle let me
know i know right what the fuck just when we're about to get
food yeah you guys have to make you guys have to be careful
if you're on the sides you should be looking if someone's
about to charge or like bite you and jump off it's just not
possible to stop what just happened to us yeah he like took
out his homeboy he didn't even hit us he like took him out
which then stunned everyone yeah that was like i mean that
gamma paid off
or is it just us two left tripping the half prime uh but
i've been bleeding because i don't have food to heal is it
just wait did ben die too ben die yeah yeah yeah there's a
bunch of he's protecting i don't know why it's always you
and me dokey i don't know why wait that means that means she
did crash dude i'm attacking some more if you guys have
health and you should go kill that guy once i stop the bleed
i go i'm bleeding pretty bad i might definitely bleed but
i'm tiny and the whole screen's red so i'm dead that's so
cringe
oh dude are you serious man what why am i the only one that
crashed too many dynas they're one of them crashed as well
yeah one of them crashed yeah okay did we at least kill the
one that crashed no don't believe so
stripping has walked up and then suddenly wait stripping i
was i was one hit from death anyway i tried to jump him well
well i'm all alone i'm all alone now The next time we play,
we can try something else.
Dude, that's so...
What did you walk up to that?
What do you mean, bro?
They killed...
Shovel while he was crashed.
Yeah, but...
You should try to 1v2 them.
Oh, how hard are you?
Are you wounded?
Wait, they're talking.
No, I'm not wounded.
Oh, they're not even wounded.
Yo, Ami, why are you guys...
Hey, Herrera's can be group size 10.
Yeah.
Got them.
Do you like that, dude?
I split into that, dude.
Well, Juju's guys.
See you next time.
They're talking about how hardcore they are.
They're talking about how what?
How much they like, they're just like, wait, one of them was
low.
Yeah, of course.
We were fucking one of them.
Well, they were.
No, no, the one that came back and like bashed into their
friend, to a friend.
That guy's low.
Yeah.
Yeah, one of them.
I mean, one of them we had three of us on him.
So before the crash.
One of them.
Yeah.
So for crashing lost us that fight like straight up.
Oh, yeah.
No, we I kill one of them if I didn't crash.
Yeah.
Yo.
Oh, hey.
Welcome back.
Where the fuck were you, man?
Annie, I think I had some important business to attend to
you.
You're all dead.
No, I'm alive.
We're all dead.
Well, I died because I crashed, which is cringe.
I'm the only one with prime left, Danny.
Looks like there's a new alpha in town, then.
Doki ran from the fight.
I did not run from the fight.
I had no stamina.
I was like, guys, I have no stamina.
I don't know how you have no stamina unless you're just
spamming jumpers.
I did not spam jump.
I swear to God, I did not spam jump.
Well, I'm getting off.
Let's do this again sometime.
Yeah.
Let's do Herrera's.
What am I going to do with my...
heroes let's let's just own a section of the woods man all
right jiu-jitsu guys
is everybody getting off yeah i mean i hate that guy man i
mean it's been like nine hours or something yeah it's been a
long time see you bye-bye guys all right um in the end i
lived with my No.
Why?
No.
I don't know why.
He's like super barking.
He has had food.
I was planning on walking him after the stream.
Sorry about the...
I'm sorry about the no James Bond, guys.
I didn't think it would go that...
Wait, I'll show you guys...
Wait, let me see if I can get sure first of all.
I think it's pretty fucking funny.
it went out i'll give you guys the replay of of what
happened before i started streaming um this was james
bondano it truly was all right let me see uh
let's see if i can get the vod up download twitch vod how do
i download twitch vod guys someone's twitch vod is there
does anyone know i don't remember is there a website oh
there you go i found it let me download this twitch vod real
quick and i'll show you guys what happened
oh it's seven hours long i hope i can download it submit i
did enter the url um dress thank you Super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, this wasn't 007.
Can't just rewatch it.
I could, but like, I don't trust myself.
I personally don't trust myself when it comes to downloading
stuff.
Like, when it comes to showing stuff on stream, because I
don't want to accidentally show something that I shouldn't
be showing.
So let me see if I can find a moment.
Let me see if I can find it.
I'm going to try to find the moment, guys.
Is it here?
I'm trying to find the moment right now.
I'm trying to find it.
Oh, is it here?
Is this where he...
I'm trying to find the moment where he was shirpaying me.
It wasn't there.
God damn it.
I don't know.
the time stamp, guys.
I'm trying to find it.
Let me see.
I'm looking through the VOD right now.
This is when we start trying to kill each other to reset our
dynos.
Where the fuck is it?
He was at the bridge.
I'm trying to find the bridge moment.
Is it here?
Okay.
Oh, I found it.
I found it, guys.
Alright, let me put that moment.
It was like right here.
Where was it?
Okay, 157.
Okay, it's right here.
Alright, let me see if I can download this.
167...
I'll do 7...
Eh, I'll do...
We'll download.
Let's see if we can do this.
See how fast this download is.
The bridge moment.
All right, we'll see how long this will take.
If it takes too long, I won't do it.
I'll just see, like, watch the VOD before I started
streaming.
But, yeah, like, Gully invited me.
I was like, have you ever played the Isle?
I was like, no.
And he's like, it's really fun.
You're going to play with us.
And I thought it would be, like, I don't know.
I thought I could play.
I thought it would end before my stream.
And it did not.
Because we kept dying a lot.
I tried to get Prime for the fucking longest time.
And then we lost Prime so fast.
We lost Prime.
So fast.
I think, I don't know if I could, would have helped if I had
stamina.
I think I would have died with them, honestly.
I think I might have died with them.
Because I can't jump.
I realized I was like, oh, I don't have stamina.
Maybe, maybe I'll just jump.
But then I was like, oh, yeah.
I was just like, oh, wait, I can't do anything.
I would have no stamina.
Who would have thought?
I didn't know that.
I'm going to clip it and see if I...
Wait, that's not it.
That's not what I want to clip.
The scarred clip.
I know I'm trying to find the bridge moment.
Where I got sure if we're killed.
Right here.
Don't worry, the next spawn stream will use the name that I
wasn't able to use earlier.
Because we had to pivot.
And then it's like, I already invested so much time in
making the aisle.
I was like, I already invested so much time trying to get
this prime shit.
I might as well go all in, you know?
Oh my god, this card clip.
I'm trying to...
grab that moment right now.
Is this not the bridge?
Where's the bridge?
Oh, this is when he, like, left me.
Oh, this is it.
There we go.
It was...
So that's why it took us a while.
That's why we pivoted.
Alright, I don't know if I can...
Bated.
Alright, let me see if I can grab this clip.
I'm saving it.
Let me see if it was the clip that I wanted to show.
I called it Bated.
It's funny how he died more times.
To be fair, I was baiting a little.
Because I didn't know!
I didn't know what it was doing.
It was my first time, guys.
It was my first time.
I'm scared of jumping on people because I didn't want to
accidentally team kill I I was scared all right guys at 99%
all right I should disconnect from I can't believe I
downloaded mumble I actually downloaded mumble for this all
right copy link is this the right clip I just looked at it
visual Julie.
Here you go.
Yes, here you go.
This is when he got really, really mad.
This was, this was the bridge.
This is when I got, um, when I got lost.
That was it.
That, let me take it.
I got lost.
He didn't tell me we were moving and I lost him.
At least I can...
At least I can find...
At least I can show you guys on stream.
At least no.
Where did I download it?
Here you go.
That's a T-Rex.
It's fine.
We have...
We have the power of science right now.
We have grass.
Yeah.
oh I see him yeah he big there's a bunch of triceratops just
chilling yeah triceratops they chill yo wait who said raptor
ready yo yo yo yo was that you t-rex dude I like how we just
are you the same t-rex from earlier guy was just like hey
guys and then like an actual killer came out we just what'd
you say if the other raptor just killed himself I can't all
right we're going across this bridge I mean one of them was
like don't anyone get really hurt donkey what are you doing
oh fuck I was muted on disc that's a T-Rex
Wait, oh, I'm muted on this.
I didn't know!
I didn't know he walked!
I was so confused.
I was like, Trubor, where are you?
No, someone else drive by and killed him, and then I
crawled, and then there was no one on the bridge, and I
crossed the bridge.
I was like, where is everyone?
to go.
I'm so scared.
Because he didn't say it because it's just me and Sherport
left alive.
We were the only ones left alive.
So I was like, where did everyone go?
Guys, I'm scared.
Let me see if that this way the VOD look.
Let me see if the VOD is good.
The Vaughn is corrupted.
Never mind.
This is a corrupted video.
Anyways.
Next week, James Vaughn for real.
I'm sorry that we got distracted with the aisle.
But five hours of aisle, though.
Five hours of aisle.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
Thank you all for hanging out with me with my Gorilla Isle
stream.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause, check, get up, and move around to get that blood
flowing.
So for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.